[Musique]
Monsieur, bonsoir.
Bonsoir. Bonsoir.
Nous sommes sur une chaîne internet.
Nous sommes en direct, une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. On vous
reçoit dans le casre de votre activité
soit proche de la finance ou avec les
doigts dans la finance. On va parler
stabilité financière,
on va parler aussi langage bancaire.
Est-ce que la banque communique d'une
façon claire ? transparente sans mettre
des lunettes roses pour présenter la
réalité.
Alors messieurs, bonsoir. Est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succintement
? On va commencer par Jérôme.
Bonsoir. Donc je m'appelle Jérôme Cazz,
j'ai longtemps été directeur général du
groupe COFAS. Je ne le suis plus depuis
maintenant plusieurs années et
aujourd'hui entre autres activités, je
soutiens l'ONG Finance Watch à
Bruxelles.
La Coface, c'était quoi ? La Cofa, c'est
une société qui fait de l'assurance
crédit, c'est-à-dire qu'elle couvre euh
les faillites des entreprise vis-à-vis
de leurs créanciers. Donc en gros, c'est
un animal qui souffre quand il y a des
crises économiques et donc ça amène à
développer une certaine agilité à se
dire quand est-ce qu'il va y avoir une
crise économique.
C'est un gros machin quand même, non ?
Bah c'est un gros machin. Disons qu'à
côté de BNP Paris-Bas, c'est un tout
petit petit machin. Mais disons dans son
petit monde, dans son écosystème, oui,
c'est un gros machin.
Christophe Nichdame, est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Alors euh moi de mon côté, j'ai été tour
à tour banquier aux États-Unis dans les
années 80 et 90. Euh puis ensuite, j'ai
été analyste financier notamment
couvrant le secteur bancaire européen
pendant la crise des subprimes. Puis
j'ai dirigé une ONG qui a été
mentionnée, Finance Watch, qui est
spécialisée sur la régulation
post-crise. J'ai également été membre
des collèges consultatifs de l'autorité
bancaire européenne et de l'autorité
européenne des marchés financiers. Euh
je suis euh actuellement euh responsable
de la recherche européenne euh de
l'ECGS. Euh le CGS c'est quoi ? C'est
une société de conseil en gouvernance
qui est dirigée par Proxinvest sur le
marché français. J'ai également enseigné
pendant 18 ans la finance à Science Po
et je viens de publier un livre qui
s'appelle La finance pour les nuls en 50
notions clés.
Bon, alors la première question, je vous
la lâche. Bon, alors on va dire la
communauté, je vous connais tous les
deux, donc on va avoir une interview un
peu plus décontracté que d'habitude.
Le système financier, il est stable, les
banques sont stables. Est-ce qu'on nous
raconte pas un petit peu du gros pipo
pour rassurer tout le monde ? Est-ce
qu'on se retrouve pas en face d'une
tempête tellement énorme que les
pouvoirs publics, les institutions
financières sont tellement tétanisé que
elle nous présente un regard de lunett
rose et que tout ira bien mais en fin de
compte c'est pas la réalité.
Qui qui reçoit la patate chaude ?
Allez, je la prends.
Euh alors, je serai peut-être pas aussi
négatif que cela comme on dit toujours.
Le pire n'est pas certain. Il en demeure
pas moins, c'est que on a quand même pas
mal de signaux à différents niveaux, que
ce soit macroéconomique, que ce soit
microéconomique, que ce soit sur les
marchés financiers, qui fait qu'il est
assez compliqué en ce moment d'être très
optimiste.
Comme vous le savez, quand on parle de
pessimisme, on dit souvent le
pessimiste, c'est un optimiste informé.
Alors, dans le cas d'espèces, quelles
sont les sources un petit peu disons de
de crainte ?
à deux niveaux. Au niveau
macroéconomique, excusez-moi, j'ai la
crève,
on voit un très net ralentissement
économique sur l'Allemagne, même chose
chez nos amis Chinois. Et du coup,
évidemment, ce ralentissement économique
se fait sentir sur les marchés
financiers, voire même sur les banques.
Alors, quand on regarde le secteur
bancaire, beaucoup de gens disent "Oui,
mais aujourd'hui, en 2019, ça n'est plus
comme en 2008. Il y a eu beaucoup de
régulations qui ont été mises en place,
les fonds propres ont été doublés et
cetera et cetera. Bon, qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire là-dessus ? Évidemment, la
régulation a été importante, les fonds
propres ont été doublés, mais il en
demeure pas moins qu'on conserve des
banque dites systémique. C'est les
fameuses banques to big to fail, trop
grosse pour faire faillite,
to jail,
to jail, too big to manage également et
qui pose actuellement un problème. Alors
la BCE, la Banque centrale européenne
qui a sous supervision les plus grosses
banques de la zone euro
a publié en début de semaine en fait il
y a il y a 48 heur des nouveaux stress
tests qui cette fois-ci portaient sur la
liquidité des banques. Alors, c'est une
grande première parce que tous les
stress tests antérieurs dont la validité
avait été disons parfois remise en cause
ne testait que la solvabilité,
c'est-à-dire est-ce que les banques ont
suffisamment de fonds propres pour
disons faire face à un choc ? Mais on ne
testait pas la liquidité.
Or le problème c'est qu'une banque comme
une entreprise normale saute toujours
sur une crise de trésorerie. Je vous
rappeler que la banque qui a qui détient
le record du monde des faillites, c'est
la franco-belge Dexia qui a fait deux
fois faillite en 2008 et en 2011 à
chaque fois sur une crise de liquidité
alors qu'elle respectait les ratios de
solvabilité.
En 2010, quand le système bancaire
irlandais s'est effondré en novembre,
c'était aussi sur une crise de liquidité
alors que les banques irlandaises
étaient passées au travers des stress
tests de solvabilité. On a eu également
la banque populare plus récemment qui
est une banque espagnole en juin 2017
qui n'avait pas de problème majeur en
terme de solvabilité mais sa liquidité
faisait problème et c'est pour ça
qu'elle avait du coup fait faillite et
été reprise par la banque sentandaire.
Alors, cette grande disons euh première
qui est enfin, alors que ça fait partie
des choses que moi j'avais demandé
depuis très nombreuses années, notamment
quand j'étais euh membre du collège
consultatif de l'Autorité bancaire
européenne, de tester la liquidité. Ces
tests, qu'est-ce qui nous donnent comme
résultat ? Alors, ça a été fait sur 103
banques de la zone euro, donc des 19
pays. La moitié tiendrait plus de 6 mois
en cas de choc sévère. Mais en fait,
quand on regarde un petit peu plus dans
le détail, il y a quand même 11 banques
sur les 103 qui ne tiendraient en terme
de trésorer et de liquidité pas plus en
fait moins de 2 mois. Et la BCE fait
remarquer très justement que finalement
les banques les plus fragiles dans ces
grosses banque, ce sont les banques
dites universelles et notamment celles
qui sont trop grosses pour faire
faillite. Alors, ironie de l'histoire,
on se souvient que le langage du lobby
bancaire a toujours été de dire "Les
banques universelles sont plus solides,
sont plus résilientes que les autres à
cause de leur modèle diversifié."
Non, en fait ces banques universelles
trop grosses pour faire faillite ne sont
pas résilientes. Elles sont tout
simplement trop grosse. Du coup, elles
ont un soutien implicite des États qui
d'ailleurs sont finalement tenues en
otage. Et là, dans le cas d'espèce, en
matière de liquidité, cette catégorie
sur les 103 banques qui ont été testées
par la BCE, les toig to fail, et bien
sur la période des 6 mois qui ont été
testés, alors le je rappelle un peu le
mécanisme qui était s'il y a un choc
extrême, combien de temps la banque
tient en terme de trésorerie.
Dans le cas d'espèce, il a été indiqué
que pour les banques dites systémiques
to big to fail,
elle perdrait au niveau du bilan, donc
en terme de trésorerie au passif 30 % de
leur bilan, ce qui est colossal
actif où elles doivent maintenir avec un
ratio qui s'appelle le ratio de
couverture de liquidité, je vous passe
les détails techniques, et non que 20 %
d'actifs dit liquide. Donc ça veut dire
quoi ? Ça veut dire que sur le papier,
sur cette catégorie là, c'est pour ça
que la BCE les a pinpointé, bah au bout
de 6 mois, il manque 10 % du bilan. 10 %
du bilan en terme de crise de
trésorerie. Alors prenez un bilan
bancaire d'une grande banque française
qui tourne à peu près 2000 milliards
d'euros, ça veut dire qu'il manquerait
200 milliards d'euros. Donc c'est pas
des sommes qui sont euh si euh faibles
que cela. Donc ça c'est quand même un
point euh disons qui qui interpel
actuellement au moment où on a un
ralentissement économique des taux
d'intérêt bas voire négatif et on pourra
en reparler qui évidemment impacte
encore plus ce modèle de banque
universelle.
Jérôme euh c'est bien beau pour
synthétiser tout ça ? Est-ce queon se
dirige vraiment vers un craque ?
Ben comme beaucoup de gens, j'en sais
rien du tout. Le le point qui est
important, c'est qu'il y aura forcément
euh une crise économique au sens d'un
ralentissement économique fort
parce que le FMI
redoute.
Redoute, mais il est payé pour ça d'une
certaine manière. Il faut à un moment
donné que la logique d'une économie de
marché c'est d'être optimiste, d'être
trop optimiste. Ça se casse la gueule,
il y a une crise et puis ça repart. Donc
les cycles euh ça fait partie de la
logique du système. Donc il y a pas
besoin d'être génal pour dire il va y
avoir euh une fin de cycle. Euh et tout
ce qu'on peut c'est essayer de la
comparer à d'autres fins de cycle parce
qu'à la fin on n'y échappera pas. C'est
de se dire est-ce qu'elle va être pire
que d'habitude
pire que la dernière grande crise et et
c'est aussi ta question. Est-ce que ça
va venir de la finance ?
Oui, il va y avoir une crise parce que
ça fait déjà pratiquement plus de 10 ans
qu'il y a eu la précédente et si on
regarde sur les cin ou six crises
antérieures en général en 8 ou 9 ans,
c'est la moyenne doit être autour de 8
ou 9 ans. Donc déjà on a eu on a eu
beaucoup de temps pour danser. En tout
cas, pour ceux qui arrivaient à danser
avec de l'argent public injecté dans les
banques. C'est ça.
Absolument. Après, il y a une deuxième
question, c'est que la crise, elle va
venir, mais ce sera pas forcément une
crise financière. Toutes les crises ne
sont pas financières. Il peut y avoir
des faillites d'entreprises en masse, on
en voit périodiquement, j'ai
l'impression qu'elles deviennent un peu
plus grande ces derniers temps. Et donc,
c'est pas forcément des banques que ça
viendra.
un élément, c'est pas d'optimisme mais
un élément
de relative modération et de dire
qu'aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
crise. Si on fait un peu d'histoire, bon
je suis un grand ancien, si on regarde
des crises antérieures, un une des une
des façons de savoir que la crise
arrive, c'est queon a un certain nombre
de gens avec des cravates qui vous
expliquent qu'il peut pas y avoir de
crise,
que ce ces trucs anciens des cycles
s'est terminé et que on a échappé à ça.
Et donc,
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a une bizarre
période où on arrête de parler de
catastrophe. En gros, dans les 18
derniers points, aujourd'hui tout le
monde continue à à être pessimiste. Donc
je pense que la crise sera peut-être pas
aussi énorme qu'on peut le craindre.
Dernier point, est-ce qu'elle sera
financière ? mon intuition et qu'elle
risque d'être financière. Parce que la
dernière crise financière, quand on en a
fait le diagnostic il y a 10 ans, on a
dit bah on aurait dû le voir venir. Il y
avait trop de crédit et on avait des
banques trop grosses.
Et un prix du pétrole en montant en
flèche ?
Ou mais là prix du pétrole en gros ça
dépend des crises, hein. Il a pas
toujours été il a pas toujours été
sur la dernière sur la dernière quand
même.
Sur la dernière oui sur la dernière.
Mais en revanche, ce qui est clair,
c'est que aujourd'hui, on a encore plus
de crédit et on a des banques encore
plus grosse. Donc
il y a des stress tests, il y a des
analyses mais la réalité c'est que
personne n'en sait rien. En gros, une
énorme banque est devenue si énorme que
son patron ne sait pas ce qu'il y a dans
les entrailles. Il ne peut pas le
savoir. Le régulateur, c'est-à-dire
celui qui est censé contrôler la bécane,
ne le sait encore moins puisque pour
l'instant, on continue à tolérer, que ce
soit les banques elles-mêmes qui
mesurent leur risque
et que elles-mêmes ne comprennent pas
bien comment ça fonctionne. Donc, on
fait des stress tests, mais tu disais
juste au titre, il y a des banques qui
tiennent pas de mois, mais on sait très
bien qu'en cas de crise, ça peut arriver
en un weekend. C'est-à-dire que à un
moment donné, les phénomènes de panique
peuvent être tels que on n pas de mois,
on n pas un mois, c'est en une semaine
qu'il faut rassurer tout le monde. Donc
aujourd'hui, la réalité c'est que
personne n'en sait rien mais qu'on a des
banques plus grosses qu'il y a 10 ans et
on a beaucoup plus de crédit qu'il y a
10 ans.
Christophe, je vais te lire un un poste
des économistes atérés. Ça dit si un
ralentissement majeur se produisait, la
dette des entreprises exposées au risque
de défaut de paiement augmente de 19000
milliards de dollars, soit près de 40 %
de la dette totale dans h économies
majeures : Allemagne, Chine, Espagne,
États-Unis, France, Italie, Japon,
Royaume-Uni, détail tel un risque de
défaut supérieur au niveau observé
pendant la crise de 2008. Oui, ça doit
être les propos de ils ont bien lu échos
de ce matin parce que c'est
effectivement le FMI qui a qui a donné
cette information là. Tout à fait, le
risque, il est fort. On va peut-être
aussi parler disons d'endettement global
parce que ce qui est assez inique, c'est
que la crise de 2007-2008 à la base est
une crise de surendettement.
et en sortie de crise, sauf que moi je
considère qu'on est toujours pas sorti
de la crise, mais disons 10 ans plus
tard, on a encore plus de dettes. Alors
deux chiffres au niveau global, là je
parle de l'endettement global des États,
des ménages et des entreprises non
financières, c'est-à-dire non pas les
banques pour éviter le double comptage.
En 2007, les dettes mondiales étaient de
milliards de dollars qui faisait à peu
près 1,7 fois le PIB de 2007. En 2017,
donc 10 ans plus tard, on se retrouve
avec un niveau d'endettement de 169000
milliards de dollars qui représente 2,1
fois le PIB. Donc oui, on a un problème
d'endettement pour éviter l'effondrement
du système et on pourra aussi évidemment
plus en parler. On a eu des politiques
monétaires très accommodantes.
Faisons un peu d'historique quand même
sur la crise en en rappelant en fait
je te coupe un peu. On a eu aussi une
politique
pénale très accommodante, non ? Qui a
été en en prison après la crise de 2008
? pas grand monde. Ça fait partie des
choses qui ont été discutées dans le
cadre d'un petit livre qu'on avait édité
avec ma coautrice Jésabelle Coupé
Souberan qui s'appelle Parlons banque en
30 questions. Nous avions dans le casre
de l'introduction notamment préconisé
mais ça évidemment ça fait pas plaisir à
grand monde disons peut-être de
pénaliser un petit peu plus certains
comportements déviants au niveau des
banques qui a eu beaucoup de scandales.
Bon, ça n'a pas ça n'a pas été fait
genre des manipulations de taux
manipulation de taux comme le Libor, le
Liborgate qui est quand même le scandale
du siècle dont on a finalement pas
suffisamment parlé parce que
le Ribor aussi hein
et le Ribor mais parce que le Laborgate
était systémique si je peux me permettre
de parler comme ça au niveau des
montants via les produits dérivés les
produits dérivés de taux qui fait que le
bidouillage qui existé pendant quelques
années anné par quelques banques s'il y
avait des procès et ça les régulateurs
se sont assurés disons de choper
quelques tradeurs mais d'éviter que les
banques en question ça remonte au sommet
parce que à ce moment-là la
responsabilité civile ce coup-ci et non
pas pénale pouvait être très importante
parce que les entreprises ou les
déposants ont été dans ce cas-là entre
guillemets spoliés. C'est le braquage du
siècle, Jérôme.
Oui, il y a il y a des crapules et elles
vont pas en prison. C'est très bien ou
c'est pas bien du tout. Mais ce qui est
ce qui est un peu effrayant dans le
système actuel pour moi, c'est que ce
qu'on félicite, prenons le président de
la Banque centrale européenne, dont on
dit qu'ils sont les sauveurs de
l'économie, ce sont des gens qui
injectent qui qui ont sauvé l'économie
en injectant du crédit. C'est-à-dire que
on est quand même dans un monde
extrêmement bizarre où après avoir tiré
un diagnostic en disant "On sait ce qui
se passe, on a trop de crédit, quelques
années après, on applaudit ce qui
injecte encore plus de crédit dans le
système." Donc oui, il faut mettre un
certain nombre de gens en tôle, ne ser
c'est la règle du jeu d'une certaine
manière. Après, on se récupère des
gilets jaunes. Si si voilà qui volent un
œuf va en tôle, qui détourne des
millions n'y va pas. Bon, c'est une
vieille règle qui fait que ça sent le
pourri quand les chefs vont pas en tôle
quand ils ont commis un mffet. Mais mais
le système à mon avis est dangereux
quand on applaudit quelqu'un dont on
sait dans une partie de son cerveau
qu'en fait on fait il fait une grosse
bêtise. Mais mais si on accepte l'idée
qu'en fait le crédit est devenu une
drogue,
on a tous les problèmes des drogués.
C'est-à-dire que une partie du cerveau
sait qu'il devrait arrêter, mais il en
est complètement incapable. Et et plus
le temps passe, plus ça devient presque
impossible d'arrêter et plus tout le
monde est terrorisé
à l'idée de qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
pour sevrer du crédit. Comment est-ce
qu'on arrête de vivre accroché au crédit
? Et aujourd'hui, personne n'arrive avec
des un plan pour dire "Je sais comment
on va faire, on va se désendetter
progressivement."
D'où l'inquiétude que la prochaine crise
ne serve plus à rien. La précédente n'a
servi à rien. Essayons que la suivante
qui va forcément venir serve à quelque
chose.
Christophe, on applaudit nos dealers,
on leur construit un petit hôtel de la
dévotion. Tout se passe bien. Le sevrage
est-il plus dangereux
que de rester encore en apesanteur avec
des crédits revolving
à échelle mondiale ? Est-ce que le
sevrage, le d'arrêter de de de de taper
dans le crédit avec le nez tout poudré,
c'est en fin de compte à court terme
mieux pour les politiques, mieux pour
les banquiers, mieux pour les traders
parce que ces gens-là savent que si on
narrête pas, si on arrête tout de suite,
c'est là que ça devient très très
dangereux pour eux.
pour eux et pour tout le monde c'est
assez compliqué hein comme disons
question et savoir comment faire.
Je reviens un petit peu à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure dans le
la première phase de la crise 2007-2008
qu'on appelle des la crise des subrime
qui était une crise mondiale.
pour éviter l'effondrement du système à
ce moment-là, au moment de la faillite
de l'Éman septembre octobre8,
un gros shoot
les États oui mais les États à ce
moment-là on n'a pas eu d'injection de
liquidité les États se sont portés
caution des banques. Dans le cadre des
Français, c'était à hauteur de 370
milliards d'euros. Soit caution, soit
augmentation de capital. Bon, ensuite,
on a eu un effet de bord, la deuxième
crise que j'appelle celle de la crise de
l'euro qui ne touchait que l'Europe et
plus les États-Unis, le reste du monde
2011-212. Et là, comme les États étaient
déjà entre guillemets un peu exang ou en
tout cas les marchés financiers
considéraient que les États s'étaient
fortement endettés dans le cadre de
cette crise, il faut pas oublier que les
déficits budgétaires ont explosé. Bah
donc mécaniquement la dette publique en
pourcentage du PIB a augmenté de l'ordre
de 30 à 40 points de PIB sur les grands
pays d'OCDE. Sur la France, on est passé
de 65 % du PIB à aujourd'hui, on est aux
alentours de de 100 %. Bref, dans cette
deuxième crise plus circonstr
à la zone euro, les États ne pouvaient
plus se porter caution de leur banque.
Donc le nouveau rempart, c'est devenu la
banque centrale, la BCE, qui a injecté
les fameux LTRO à hauteur de 1000
milliards d'euros pour donner des
liquidités aux banques. Ça a pas été
suffisant.
Donc le dealer a pas suffisamment
fourni.
Voilà. Enfin, c'est pas qu'elle a pas
suffisamment fourni, c'est que
finalement cette drogue
sa cam c'était de la merde.
Mais c'est pas que c'était de la merde,
c'est que ça ne résit ça ne résolvait
pas le problème, sauf temporairement
pour éviter l'effondrement du système.
Comme cette crise d'endettement à la
base, toute crise d'endettement est plus
longue à résorber qu'une crise liée aux
capitaux propres. Alors, je vais vous
prendre deux exemples. Vous vous
souvenez peut-être de la crise le le la
crise boursière, le craque boursier
d'octobre
1987 où on avait perdu 20 % en une
journée. 6 mois plus tard, tout allait
bien. Pourquoi ? C'était juste la bourse
qui avait baissé et c'était pas un
problème de surendettement. Quand on a
eu le dégonflement de la bulle internet
2001 20002
2003, bon là aussi c'était une crise des
fonds propres. Les gens sont allés jouer
au casino sur les valeurs internet qu'on
appelait les TMT. Ils ont été lessivés,
ils sont sortis du casino, ils n'avaient
que leurs yeux pour pleurer mais ça
s'est arrêté là. En 2007 et les années
subséquentes, les gens sont allés jouer
au casino mais avec l'argent des autres.
Ils sont fait rincer, ils sortent du
casino et là il y a un mal àabar avec
une grosse batte de baseball
qui lui demande ou leur demande il est
où mon pognon ? Et derrière ce mal
làbas, il y a un autre mal làbas encore
plus costaud avec une massu plus
importante qui est lui dit "Mais
n'oublie pas que tu me dois aussi du
pognon". Donc une crise d'endettement
c'est très difficile à dessin je fais
trait si je peux me permettre parce que
il y a toutes ces relations
contractuelles qu'il faut c'est comme un
plat de spaghettis. Donc les premiers
LTRO de 1000 milliards d'injection de
liquidité n'ont pas fonctionné. Donc on
a eu la deuxème dose, le deuxième shoot
qui est les fameux QI, donc quantitative
easing assouplissement quantitatif
moyen non conventionnel qui dans le
cadre de la BCE a quand même porté sur
un peu plus de 2600 milliards d'euros.
Aujourd'hui, on a la BCE, comme je dis
un peu vulgairement, qui a les dents du
fond qui baignent parce que le bilan de
la BCE fait 4600 milliards d'euros, ce
qui représente 40 % du PIB de la zone
euro. C'est colossal. Alors ça c'était
pour éviter l'effondrement du système
mais la conséquence ça a été une baisse
des taux voire même des taux négatifs.
Et le problème de ces taux bas voire
négatif
il est disons, il y en a beaucoup
plusieurs.
Alors le premier parlons des banques
universelles. Vous savez celles qui sont
descendues du ciel comme Jésus-Christ
avec la banque universelle tout allait
bien. Une banque universelle c'est
principalement quatre métiers. Donc
imaginez un petit peu un tabouret avec
quatre pieds.
Le premier pied c'est la banque de
détail, ce qu'on appelle le retail
banking. Donc c'est les guichets. Ce
métierlà, il souffre des tobas, non
seulement des tobas, mais aussi de
l'aplatissement de la courbe des taux.
Alors la courbe des taux, ça veut dire
quoi ? C'est normalement en période de
croissance et quand on n'est pas en
crise, les taux à long terme sont
supérieurs au taux à court terme. C'est
comme ça que la banque gagne son argent.
gagne son argent et non pas de façon
malhonnête. Ben là, les taux étant
désormais plat, la marge nette d'intérêt
sur un crédit immobilier consenti par
une banque à un particulier, bah elle se
retrouve écrasée. Donc ça c'est le
premier pied du tabouret qui est sillé.
Les trois autres pieds sont aussi sés en
même temps. Le deuxième pied, c'est la
BFI, ce qu'on appelle la banque de
financement et d'investissement, donc la
banque d'affaires. Dans ces métierslà,
les activités dites de marché ont gagné
tranquillement sa vie en faisant ce
qu'on appelait du carry trade. Donc vous
êtes market makers, teneur de marché,
vous donnez un prix à un institutionnel
qui veut vendre avant l'échéance une
obligation, admettons à 10 ans à un
coupon de 6 % sur EDF. La banque achète
cette obligation à 6 % et se refinance
grâce à une courbe des taux euh positive
à admettons 2 % et là en en grange
également la la profitabilité avec les
taux plats. Ça ça s'ouvre. Les
assurances les assurances surtout en
France c'est les assurances vies he les
assurances vies finalement c'est sorte
de complément de retraite pour les
Français
sur des obliques d'état.
Sur des obliques d'état ce sont les
fonds en euros. Vous avez vu depuis
quelques semaines que ici et là tout le
monde est en train de dire en terme
d'assureur vie, bah ça va pas le faire,
on va plus pouvoir garantir les taux à 2
ou 3 %. Ça souffre. Le dernier métier,
c'est la gestion d'actifs, ce qu'on
appelle les asset managers.
Les par exemple Amundi dans le cadre du
groupe Crédit Agricole. Là, dans ce
métier-là, vous avez des commissions de
gestion puisque vous gérez de l'argent
pour compte de tiers, mais vous
n'arrivez plus dans cet environnement
taux faible voire négatif à justifier
une commission d'admettons 1 % sur un
fond obligators que les obligues en
question rapportent au client final plus
rien. Donc
le client final, ça peut être aussi un
un fond de pension des retraites.
Ça peut-être une caisse de retraite, un
fond de pension ou monsieur Duchemol.
Tout à fait. Monsieur Duchemol en fait,
il peut se faire rincer.
Alors là, il se fait rincer en ce sens
que la rentabilité
de l'investissement euh qui est fait au
travers de la d'une sicave obligataire
ne rapporte plus rien. Ça veut pas dire
qu'il se fasse rincer, ça veut dire que
ça rapporte rien.
Ouais. Mais si l'inflation derrière
augmente,
alors pour l'instant l'inflation
n'augmente pas trop.
Cela dit, ce que vous dites est exact
parce que finalement
quand on regarde l'environnementaux,
donc l'inflation est inférieure à ce qui
est serait souhaité par la BCE, donc on
est bien inférieur au 2 %, j'arrondis,
on est à 1 %. On a désormais des taux
négatifs, notamment en Allemagne sur des
échéances à 10 ans où les obligations
des emprunts d'État allemand sont en
négatif aux alentours de 12 %.
Donc celui qui détient des empreints
d'État allemand effectivement subit une
érosion monétaire de 1 et demi pour par
an d'inflation plus le taux négatif de
0,50. Et il est vrai que sur 10 ans,
avec la composition des intérêts, donc
les intérêts qui font des intérêts, qui
font des petits sauf que plus les taux
sont bas, plus la composition des
intérêts est faible, on perd 16 % du
capital sous forme d'érosion monétaire.
C'est beau, c'est magnifique. C'est pour
ça que certaines banques ont commencé à
taxer les dépôts de plus de 100000 €
dans certains pays. Oui. En France,
scandinave, allemand.
Exact. Et et suisse. Et surtout et
surtout les Suisses.
Tout à fait. C'est un c'est un vrai
problème. Je ne pense pas que ça va
arriver en France mais
parce qu'il y a pas de 100000 € c'est ça
? Non, c'est pas parce Non, c'est plus
parce que en France, par rapport à
d'autres pays, on a toujours une un
système organisé du nini, c'est-à-dire
que on ne rémunérait pas les comptes
courants et du coup euh ces comptes
courants n'étaient pas entre guillemets
facturés par les banques. Quand il
facturé, on payait pas son carnet de
chèque. Euh donc
les frais bancaires ont augmenté de 1087
%.
Les frais bancaires ont effectivement
explosé. Tout à fait. Mais ça n'est pas
euh la taxe parce que finalement ça
revient à une taxe quand vous avez un
taux d'intérêt négatif que l'on voit
dans les pays scandinav chez certaines
banques allemandes, chez les Suisses et
ou chez des banques suisses installées
en France.
La banque Rootschield effectivement
enfin c'est c'est pas une banque très
importante, c'est une banque un peu
particulière
a dit d'y évoquer ou disons envisager ce
sujet. À mon avis, une banque française
qui ferait cela se tirerait une balle
dans le pied parce que du jour au
lendemain, il y aurait un bank run,
c'est-à-dire ah bon bah mon argent, je
vais le prendre et je vais le mettre
ailleurs. Et ce momentlà, il y aurait
une crise de trésorerie pour la banque
en question.
Je sais d'ailleurs pas si tout le monde
comprend bien ce que ça a de choquant
cette idée de taux d'intérêt négatif.
C'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné, j'ai
de l'argent et je le mets quelque part
en disant "Je suis d'accord que vous
m'en rendiez moins dans quelques temps."
Euh qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
profondément sur la la réalité de notre
économie qui est des gens qui mettent
des paquets d'argent en disant
"J'accepte que vous m'en rendiez moins"
? Pour moi, ça dit deux choses. La
première c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
d'euros de crédit. Je reviens sur mon
point. On est dans une société droguée
au crédit. on en injecte partout et à un
moment donné, c'est un peu comme quand
les pêches tombent à zéro, on se dit "On
a trop produit de pêche." Premier
message quand même qu'on devrait
entendre avec ces taux d'intérêt
négatif, c'est de se dire "On n'est pas
en train de faire trop de crédit."
Le deuxième message euh qu'on doit
entendre là-dessus, c'est un message de
risque. Si des gens, les gens qui font
des gros placements, tu parlais de
100000 € tout à l'heure, mais ça peut
être 100 millions d'euros, c'est des
gens qui ont beaucoup d'argent, qui ont
des bons systèmes d'information.
Si j'ai 100 millions d'euros
et que je l'ai et que je les prête à
l'État français ou à l'état allemand en
disant ça fait rien, tu m'en rendras
moi, c'est pas grave.
c'est que j'ai une trouille bleue de
mettre cet argent à la banque.
Et donc ce que signale quand même un
taux d'intérêt négatif, c'est une
inquiétude viscérale d'un certain nombre
de gens très au courant à mettre leur
argent comme on dit vulgairement à la
banque. Et les banques elles-mêmes
mettent des tomberaux d'argent à la
banque centrale où elles sont obligées,
elles perdent un peu chaque jour de
cette valeur plutôt qu'aller les mettre
chez les copines.
d'une certaine manière un taux d'intérêt
négatif et à mon sens un indice
formidablement malsin pour une économie
et pour une économie financière.
D'autant plus que finalement enfin
l'argent gratuit pousse à une disons une
mauvaise allocation des capitaux.
Euh il y a des gens dont toi d'ailleurs
qui disent souvent l'argent gratuit
pousse à faire des bêtises.
Ça entraîne des nouvelles bulles. Quand
on regarde par exemple le marché
immobilier résidentiel français, on est
dans un mécanisme de bulle
extraordinaire
avec un taux de crédit immobilier qui
est aux alentours de 1,32
% avant peu importe les les les coûts
d'assurance. Et là, on a une partie de
ces liquidités
qui sont recyclées dans des crédits
immobiliers sur de l'ancien. Je suis
désolé, je sais que ça fait pas plaisir
à beaucoup de gens quand je dis ça, mais
c'est stérile. Un immobilier ancien, le
prix monte bien, mais c'est stérile. Ça
n'est pas comme des constructions
nouvelles ou des entreprises. Alors, le
crédit immobilier en France sur les
banques françaises aujourd'hui, c'est à
peu près 1050 milliards d'euros.
à quelques milliards d'euros près, c'est
le même montant mais pas plus que le
crédit consenti par les banques
françaises aux entreprises. Les
entreprises, elles normalement bah elles
font fonctionner l'économie. C'est c'est
l'économie réelle. Dans les signes que
tu viens de mentionner et j'ai j'ai lu
ce matin et c'est effectivement un autre
signe. Prenons le cas de la Grèce. Bon,
la Grèce pays compliqué.
Sans parler des raisons de la crise
grecque, on va malheureusement quand
même se rappeler d'une grosse
défaillance. La Grèce ce matin a
emprunté à 3 mois à un taux négatif
de 0,02 % de points de base. Bon, c'est
pas le cas de la France ou l'Allemagne,
mais c'est un un autre signe précurseur
de dire que sur les marchés financiers,
un pays qui a la réputation d'avoir été
défaillant, on est prêt à lui mettre de
l'argent gratos ou un léger taux
négatif. Alors, toujours dans ces
problèmes un peu de défiance,
on peut dire ça aussi pour les
entreprises parce qu'il y a un instant,
on parlait des faillites d'entreprise.
Euh aujourd'hui euh comme il y a trop de
crédit, qu'on sait pas où le fourguer,
euh un certain nombre de banquiers
supplie les entreprises et arrivent avec
des idées auprès des entreprises. Alors
ça peut être les rachats d'action dont
tu parlais tout à l'heure, ça peut être
n'importe quoi pour leur dire "Vous êtes
stupide de pas vous endetter plus."
Et là, en tant qu'assure crédit,
c'est-à-dire assureur crédit qui est
intéressé au financier mais aussi à
l'économie réelle, je pense qu'il y a un
certain nombre de boises saines qui ont
compris de la crise de 2008 que
s'endetter était une énorme bêtise parce
que les banquiers pouvaient vous retirer
le tapis au mauvais moment, mais il y a
un certain nombre d'entreprises qui ont
pas le choix et que aujourd'hui se
rendent compte qu'elles obtiennent à peu
près ce qu'elles veulent. Pour ça, je
disais la crise, elle peut venir de la
finance, elle peut aussi ce sera quand
même viendra indirectement de la
finance. Mais ça peut très bien se
traduire par une marée de de faillite
d'entreprise.
Au niveau des particuliers, cette
défiance, on la voit à deux niveaux. Euh
d'une part, les billets de banque euh
donc émis par la BCE euh ont augmenté de
50 % entre 2009 et aujourd'hui. C'est de
l'ordre de 1250 milliards d'euros et on
pense qu'il y a à peu près 600 milliards
sur ces 1250 qui sont pas pour des
transactions en cash mais qui sont mis
sous les matelas. Bon, ça c'est le
premier facteur qui
une connerie monumentale d'ailleurs
moins cher que les taux d'intérêt
négatif.
C'est-à-dire que vu le prix de location
d'un coffre et le volume qu'occupe des
billets, à un moment donné, il vaut
mieux aller mettre des billets au coffre
qu'aller payer
négatif.
S'il y a un défaut de l'euro ou il y a
un défaut, une crise comme ça, ça vaut
plus rien.
Alors ce là, c'est une fuite devant la
monnaie, devant l'euro. D'accord. Oui,
mais ça vaut plus rien.
Beaucoup de choses ne vaudront plus rien
à ce moment-là. Faudra acheter un fusil.
Euh et puis accumuler du sucre et de
l'huile. Et
c'est pas ce qui se passe en ce moment.
On a reçu Gelgiro euh qui nous a dit
qu'il avait des copains. Oui. Qui Giro ?
Très bien. Je connais bien.
Euh on lui a dit on lui a dit euh bah
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Il nous a
dit textuellement euh on a des copains
euh qui commencent à acheter des terres
en Suède parce qu'ils se disent que le
réchauffement climatique ça va pas trop
les toucher là-bas. Ils se prennent des
locations de boomker,
ils ont des plans d'exfiltration des
grandes villes urbaines.
Non, ça vous a pas chatouillé les
oreilles d'entendre des choses comme ça
?
Alors moi, je n'ai rien entendu sur
sujet. Maintenant, est-ce qu'il y a des
gens qui se posent ce type de question ?
Certainement.
Des gens très bien informés.
Des gens très bien informés, j'en sais
rien. Oui. Enfin, peut-être.
Bah, d'une certaine manière, quelqu'un
qui a beaucoup d'argent, c'est très bien
qu'il va pas être vraiment touché par le
réchauffement climatique ou alors il le
sera 50 ans après les autres. Donc oui,
ce genre de comportement
existe sûrement. Mais mais le point qui
me paraît vraiment essentiel, c'est pour
la personne moyenne, modeste qui est pas
qui qui a pas la possibilité d'aller
s'acheter un bunker en en Suède.
Kalashnikov, c'est 500 € hein.
Pardon ?
Kalashnikov, c'est 500 €. Oui, mais ça
suffit pas quand même à vivre si
c'est pour piquer des billets qui valent
plus rien. Enfin, je sais pas, il y a
des ça marche plus trop. Mais la la
question c'est de se dire en effet, il
peut y avoir un jour euh une fuite
devant la monnaie, tout est possible.
euh on peut faire toujours plus noir que
noir, mais là, on tombe sur un autre
problème qui est de dire que euh dans
notre système, ceux à qui on a confié la
monnaie, c'est les banques. C'est-à-dire
que notre monnaie, elle est basée sur le
crédit. Ceux qui créent la monnaie,
c'est les banques. Et quand on veut
créer de la monnaie,
à partir de rien,
on le donne aux banques. C'est-à-dire
qu'on permet aux banques de faire euh du
crédit. Donc d'une certaine manière,
c'est là qu'on voit que la collectivité
et derrière les États qui sont quand
même les représentants de la
collectivité politiquement est un peu
coincé parce qu'à un moment donné, c'est
le même problème que tu disais tout à
l'heure, c'est-à-dire d'une certaine
manière, on est devenu les otages des
banques pour tout ce qui concerne le
crédit mais on est aussi devenu les
otages des banques pour ce qui concerne
la monnaie. C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui
on ne peut plus, un citoyen, j'en ai
rencontré, moi j'ai un peu cette
question aussi, mais où est-ce que je
pourrais mettre mon argent euh en étant
sûr qu'il va pas servir à faire des
cochonneries, des trucs qui me
révoltent, des trucs dangereux, je sais
pas quoi, de la spéculation ou et en
fait on peut pas on peut pas parce que
d'une certaine manière le système a été
bâti pour dire la monnaie banque
centrale, celle qui finalement est le le
le sanctuaire de la la collectivité.
Oui, la France peut se casser la figure
globalement, mais à un moment donné la
collectivité française, la sécurité de
la collectivité française, c'est la
monnaie banque centrale. Et la monnaie
banque centrale, qui est ce qui a accès
seulement ? C'est les banques. Donc en
gros, on dit si vous voulez de la
sécurité, vous allez dans une banque.
Mais du coup, moi collectivité état, je
suis obligé de protéger la banque sinon
évidemment tous mes tous mes citoyens
sont couillonnés. Et donc je pense qu'à
un moment donné, il y a un problème sur
le crédit. C'estàd qu'il faut revoir
comment est-ce qu'on on distribue le
crédit. Mais il y a aussi un problème
sur la monnaie, c'estàd comment est-ce
qu'on arrive à sortir la monnaie des
banques et comment est-ce qu'on arrive à
donner aux citoyens lambda la sécurité
de la monnaie banque centrale. Les
Hollandais sont assez avancés là-dessus.
Il y a il y a des techniques mais ça
oblige à repenser comment est-ce que
fonctionne la finance aujourd'hui.
C'est c'est pas trop tard de leur
retirer leur pouvoir ces banques ?
Est-ce que le le wagon va tellement vite
que les freins ne sont plus du tout
opératifs et et on est on est coincé
avec un monstre qui est tout big to
fail, to big to jail, c'est trop gros
pour aller en prison.
tellement interconnecté
que la situation devient inextricable.
On n'est jamais trop gros pour ne pas
mourir. C'est je pense que les très très
gros font en effet des grosses conneries
et tout ce qu'on voudra
mais à un moment donné Black Rock mais
moi je je reviendrai alors encore plus
ancien. Je je lisais l'autre jour les
compagnies des la compagnie des Indes.
On a oublié tout ça mais au 18e au 19e
siècle c'était des entreprises privées
qui étaient d'une taille mais
monstrueuse à qui on avait délégué la la
gestion de l'Inde. c'est-à-dire
quasiment un continent qui avait des
armées, qui avait de la monnaie et et
ils ont disparu en 20 ans parce qu'ils
ont fait des trop grosses bêtises et
qu'à un moment donné, on a sonné la fin
de la récrée. Donc pour moi, la question
elle est de dire combien il nous faudra
de crise avant qu'on sonne la fin de la
récrée. Mais forcément, on sera obligé
de la sonner parce que on peut pas
confier des choses essentielles à des
gros animaux aussi fragiles. Christophe,
est-ce que les fous ont Je vais la la
question va être en deux parties. Est-ce
que les fous ont pris le contrôle de
l'asile ? Et la deuxème, si je te dis il
y a deux façons de de mettre une
population en esclavage. Il y a par les
armes et par la dette.
Alors sur la première question, est-ce
que les fous ont pris la direction de
l'asile ? Bon, difficile pour moi de me
prononcer. Donc je passe.
Tu connais trop de fous, c'est ça ? Non,
c'est pas ça. C'est que bon c'est enfin
ça me parle pas trop donc j'ai du mal à
y répondre.
Quand quand quand la BCE déverse du
crédit à gogo alors qu'on sait
pertinemment que c'est déflationniste.
Quand la BCE déverse encore son son
pognon un peu partout et que on voit
bien que ça ne fonctionne pas parce que
on peut prendre l'exemple du Japon, ça
fait des années et des années que le
Japon nous fait du crédit à gogo avec
plus de 297 % de de d'endettement.
C'est pas c'est pas des fous.
Alors, je dirais pas que ce sont des
fous, ce sont des gens qui se trompent.
C'est
voilà, les conséquences peuvent être
dramatiques. Là où je suis effectivement
d'accord, c'est se trompe bien parce que
on l'a vu avec ce qui a été fait donc il
y a une quinzaine de jours par Dragy,
donc dans le cadre de sa sortie où il
remet une couche de la même chose qui a
échoué. Bon oui mais ça il y a des gens
moi j'en connais mais qui sont pas
obligatoirement des fous
totalement échoués on continue à jouer.
Le problème c'est de continuer à jouer
dans sa logique il a pas échoué.
Non alors quand je dis échoué c'est
échouer au niveau de relancer
l'inflation et ou la croissance
économique qui qui n'est toujours pas
là.
Jérôme Jérôme
oui mais enfin on est on n'est pas en
récession non plus. C'est pourquoi
est-ce que en gros on lui trace des
lauriers ? C'est dire, je pense que à un
moment donné, les anglais disent
conventional wisdom, c'est la la sagesse
moyenne.
La sagesse moyenne aujourd'hui, c'est de
dire "On fera ce qu'on pourra mais on
mettra tout le crédit qu'il faut." Et et
il y a toujours un petit effet, de moins
en moins, c'est comme la drogue, ça fait
de moins en moins de plaisir mais il y a
toujours un petit effet. Donc le
problème c'est qu'on a peut-être besoin
de fous pour en sortir. Les les gens qui
sont aujourd'hui au aux manettes, ils
ont bâti un corpus intellectuel dans
lequel ils sont un peu prisonniers mais
qui a une énorme cohérence. Mais donc
ils ne sont pas fous.
Ils sont pas fous. Non, je crois pas
qu'ils soit fous. En revanche, un moment
donné, le fou c'est celui qui dit le roi
est nu ou c là c'est le petit enfant.
Mais enfin le fou c'est celui qui dit
"Mais attendez, vous vous êes vous vous
rendez compte que si on prolonge la
courbe que vous avez là, à un moment
donné, on arrive à un mur. Donc est-ce
qu'on attend d'être au mur ou est-ce
qu'on on donne un tour de volant avant
?" Et ça c'est vrai que après on va dire
"Ah bah oui, mais ça c'est des
utopistes,
c'est des crapaufous."
Oui, mais ils auront raison à un moment
donné malheureusement. Et et on peut
très bien être cynique en disant
malheureusement l'humanité n'arrive à
tourner son volant que dans des
situations de crise.
La deuxième question c'était quoi
sur le la façon de mettre une population
en esclavage soit par les armes, soit
par la dette.
Alors, je parlerai plutôt par la dette,
moi, que par que par les armes.
C'est doux, c'est tranquille.
Euh
tout à l'heure, j'ai dit mais à juste
titre, c'est que la crise qui avait
démarré en 2007 était une crise
d'endettement et de surendettement. Et
le côté inique, c'est que 10 12 ans plus
tard, on a encore plus de dettes. Bon
euh mon analyse toute personnelle et je
suis un libéral, je le précise, n
parfait. Non mais pour voilà exactement
mais pour que on ne croit pas que je
suis un cryptomarxiste.
Quand j'étais patron de Finance Watch,
on m'a appelé tous les noms parce qu'on
pensait que bon bref,
quand il y a eu la chute du mur de
Berlin en 89, euh finalement la
conséquence de cela, je dis pas que qui
était peut-être une bonne chose parce
que vivre sous le j de l'empire
soviétique, ça devait pas être drôle
tous les jours, mais ça a été célébré
comme la victoire du libéralisme par
rapport au collectivisme. Et donc du
coup, on a une vague de néolibéralisme
qui n'avait plus de contrepouvoir
idéologique et qui s'en est donné à
corgeis. Cette financiarisation
excessive qui nous a amené dans la
crise, c'est bien la résultante de la
chute du mur de Berlin et de la
dérégulation financière qui a suivi.
Pour maintenir une certaine cohésion
sociale ou sociétale pendant donc depuis
près de 30 ans quelque chose comme ça.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ?
On a donné du crédit facilement aux gens
au lieu de leur donner du pouvoir
d'achat. Donc ça a été un mouvement qui
était plus favorable disons aux
actionnaires. De moi dans mon métier, je
défends plutôt quand même les
actionnaires, mais ce qu'on appelait le
shareorder value et cetera. Mais du coup
pour pouvoir donner un peu plus de
valeur aux actionnaires, on a restreint
la fonction salaire coût du travail. Et
pour qu'il y ait pas trop, disons de
gens qui gueulent en disant "Ouais, bon
pour maintenir leur niveau de vie, ben
on leur affilé du crédit à de balles
pour s'acheter un écran plat ou une
nouvelle voiture." Donc oui, c'est une
forme d'esclavage parce que normalement
le partage disons des fruits de la
croissance qui aurait dû être équilibré
entre les apporteurs de capitaux, les
actionnaires et puis les salariés qui
est la main d'œuvre qui est le travail,
on n' pas eu ça et on les a endetté. Or,
le problème de la dette, c'est que ça
crée des crises dont il est plus
difficile de s'en sortir et surtout
c'est qu'il faut essayer de la
rembourser cette dette. C'est pas la
même chose si je reçois une augmentation
de salaire et que je la dépense pour
m'acheter un écran plat que si je me
prends un crédit revolver sur 24 mois.
Juste peut-être dire un mot sur cette
histoire du du crédit d'ailleurs.
Oui. Le crédit manière au fond de de
dominer.
Je suis alors tu es libéral. Moi, je
suis pas religieux mais c'est quand même
intéressant de voir que toutes toutes
les religions que je connais, je suis
pas un grand spécialiste non plus de la
religion, mais toutes les religions
jette l'eau probre sur le crédit, l'ont
même interdit. L'usure
euh ou non, le crédit le crédit a été
euh jugé néfaste par les grandes relux.
Pourquoi ? Et et il me semble qu'il faut
bien voir la brutalité qu'il y a dans le
crédit, c'est-à-dire
un pari sur l'avenir. À un moment donné,
le crédit a été source d'esclavage parce
que OK, je te prête quelque chose et tu
t'engages à me le rendre dans un an.
C'est rien ou sans intérêt. Moi, je suis
très frappé par un compte d'enfant qui
m'avait très frappé dans ma jeunesse où
le diable donne toutes les richesses que
il veut à un jeune étudiant à condition
que quand il viendra un an après, il
puisse lui rendre ne serait-ce qu'une
pièce d'or. Et en fait avec cette
aisance absolument illimitée, l'étudiant
fait n'importe quoi pendant un an et
puis quand le diable revient, il a même
pas une pièce d'or. C'est le problème du
crédit, c'est pas l'intérêt, c'est pas
l'usure. Le problème du crédit, c'est le
déséquilibre qu'il a à fixer quelque
chose pour dans l'avenir. Et je rajoute
et et on prend l'Inde, on prend dans des
tas de pays, le crédit était le levier
de de l'esclavage. C'està-dire qu'à un
moment donné, tu m'as dit que tu me
rembourserais et tu l'as pas. Et
qu'est-ce que tu fais ? Et ben voilà, tu
vas travailler gratuitement pour moi
pendant les siècles des siècles parce
que de toute façon tu arriveras jamais à
rembourser. Donc le crédit en lui-même
est énormément déséquilibré. On lui a
donné un aspect plus sympathique
aujourd'hui mais à la fin des fins, on a
quand même un très très gros qui dit à
un petit attention, tu vas me
rembourser. Et qui après dit "Mais
regardez, il sait pas gérer son foyer et
donc je vais lui saisir c'est je sais
pas quoi. Je vais l'expulser." Donc le
crédit en lui-même est brutal. Le crédit
doit être géré comme quelque chose de
dangereux, comme un médicament.
C'est pas ce qui se passe en ce moment.
Euh les banques euh nous ont donné
toutes les richesses du monde, euh nous
ont accordé du crédit, du crédit, du
crédit et est-ce que euh ils vont nous
réclamer en fin de compte une pièce d'or
qu'on pourra pas leur donner et on va se
retrouver tous en enfer. Ben, c'est le
moment où on doit en gros se déshabituer
du crédit. C'est très très dur et c'est
pas uniquement le problème des banques.
Ce sera chacun d'entre nous qui à un
moment donné devront vivre,
je l'espère quand même un jour avec un
peu moins de crédit dans
Quand tu dis quand tu dis c'est chacun
d'entre nous, mais est-ce que tu es pas
en train de dire que c'est aussi les
politiques qui font de la subordnation
de vote avec du crédit et de la dette ?
Bah
c'est tellement facile. Bien sûr, d'une
certaine manière. C'est pour ça que le
système tient, c'est parce qu'il a une
très grande cohérence.
Je vais légèrement nuancer
en disant quand même que à cause des
tobats voire négatifs, on se trouve dans
disons sur un plan historique dans la
plus grande période de répression
financière qu'on a jamais connu. C'est
ce que Kanes appelait l'euthanasie des
rentiers, voir des épargnants. Là, on se
retrouve actuellement finalement dans ce
scénario
où il y a un transfert ou une
redistribution
de de ressources de richesse pas énorme
des épargnants vers les emprunteurs
avec des taux extrêmement faibles.
Moi, je suis je suis du côté de
l'actionnaire, moi je suis du côté du
salarié. Non, je je crois je crois
qu'aujourd'hui je crois qu'aujourd'hui
euh d'une certaine manière tout le
système de la banque centrale,
c'est-à-dire je mets de l'argent pour
faire baisser les taux, c'est un système
de distribution d'une injustice totale
puisqu'en fait ceux qui vont gagner de
l'argent quand monsieur Dragy baisse les
taux, c'est tous ceux qui ont des actifs
financiers. Et les actifs financiers,
ils sont pas répandus comme le sel dans
la soupe. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
endroits de la soupe où il y a plus de
sel que d'autres. Il y a des gens qui
ont plus de placement financier que
d'autres. Quand on essaie de regarder
sur les les 10 dernières années de
politique de banque centrale,
l'augmentation de valeur des actifs
financiers qu'il y a eu grâce à la
baisse des taux, c'est absolument
obsède.
Non, tout à fait. Non, mais et en plus,
il est pas encore euthanasier notre bon
rentier. Ben, le petit rentier, il est
bien euthanasier. Regarde nos amis
allemands qui gueulent comme des putois
parce que leur épargne locale et les
Allemands épargnent beaucoup.
probablement un peu trop, ils
considèrent qu'ils sont qu'ils sont
laminés. Je disais ça c'est juste un
petit peu pour disons
pour sauver la phase du libéral. Non,
c'est pas la phas libérale. C'est c'est
pour dire qu'il y a parfois deux
facettes à un même problème et que bah
il y a un transfert énorme. Je suis
d'accord avec toi en matière d'inégalité
et de certaines richesses, mais il y a
un transfert énorme, comme diraient nos
amis allemands, des fourmis
vers les cigales.
Au travers du crédit, il est peu cher.
Le problème, c'est que les taux vont
monter un jour ou l'autre et que les
dégâts vont être colossaux.
Alors, on ça ça tombe bien que que tu
abordes le sujet.
Est-ce que réellement les taux vont
remonter ? Parce que on on a on a mis le
scénario en branle. Si les taux
remontent d'un pouem, tout le monde est
rincé.
Tu nous expliques ça ?
Je sais pas comment l'expliquer. Je dis
qu'on est cornéisé. En fait, quand je
dis on est le système est cornéisé. Pour
éviter son effondrement, les banques
centrales à tort mais ont inondé de
liquidité. Euh l'inondation de liquidité
fait que nous avons des bulles et
l'inondation de liquidité fait que si on
remonte les taux, on a une nouvelle
catastrophe. Donc en fait pour sauver le
système, on a mis le germe de la
prochaine crise. Alors je sais pas quand
est-ce qu'elle va se déclencher,
personne ne le sait. Si c'était aussi
simple, il suffirait de shorter le
marché pour devenir immensément riche.
Mais oui, les banques centrales et les
politiques sont un peu cornéisées, mais
on ne peut pas éternellement, comme tu
le dis à Gist titre, vivre à crédit ou
avec trop de liquidité parce qu'encore
une fois des il y a des allocations de
capitaux qui vont dans des endroits
stériles
comme l'immbaumilier résidentiel, comme
le fait qu'il y a des canards boîteux
qui sont soutenus. Le cas du Japon est
assez connu là-dessus hein où il y a des
canards boîteux qui sont soutenus à bout
de bras depuis
des grosses boîtes
des grosses boîtes depuis depuis
longtemps et donc on
en France non
certaines mais bon ou certaines bon mais
on se retrouve dans le mécanisme de de
Walking Dead quoi. C'est bon ça peut pas
durer éternellement.
Je n'ai pas la solution
mais comme Jérôme l'a dit on a un
problème de sevrage. Comment le traiter
? peut-être en étant brutal, enfin quand
je dis brutal,
en déclenchant la prochaine crise
et en essayant de la contrôler. C'est
ça.
Mais je suis pas sûr qu'on ait les
moyens d'avoir une troisème crise. C'est
surtout ça qui quand je dis les moyens
sociaux et politiques
de confiance.
De confiance. Bah la confiance elle est
elle est plus làin. Quand je disais 600
milliards d'euros sous les matelas, le
fait qu'on préfère laisser de l'argent
auprès d'un état avec un taux négatif
est quand même significatif d'une
absence de de confiance.
Moi, je suis un utopiste,
donc j'ai pas de solution pour demain,
mais j'ai des solutions pour après
demain. Euh et et à mon sens, on
arrivera à reprendre le le taureau par
les cornes que le jour où on acceptera
de remettre à plat
et le rôle finalement de des banques
dans le crédit. Euh l'idée de départ
pour moi, elle est simple, c'est de dire
que le crédit c'est pas comme les pommes
de terre, c'est pas un truc plus j'en
ai, plus je suis content ou les frites.
Euh c'est comme un médicament, c'estàd
il y a une bonne dose. Si j'en ai pas
besoin, j'en ai pas besoin. Et et la
bonne dose, c'est zéro. Et puis si j'en
ai besoin, j'ai besoin de 10 mais j'ai
surtout pas besoin de 20. Et puis 5, ça
va pas suffire. Donc quand on essaie de
réfléchir à ça, on se dit "Mais
attendez, il y a un produit qui
ressemble à ça. Ça s'appelle le
médicament."
Le médicament, c'est un produit où si
j'en ai pas besoin, j'en prends pas et
si j'en ai besoin, je prends la bonne
dose et personne ne va dire qu'on va
inonder le marché de médicament parce
que ça sert à rien. Donc on voit qu'à un
moment donné la santé financière c'est
comme la santé physique et donc ça passe
par une bonne distribution du crédit. Il
se trouve que les humains qui sont quand
même pas complètement idiots ont inventé
en médecine un système de distribution
qui tient la route. C'est-à-dire qu'il
dit premièrement, on contrôle les
produits à la sortie pour pas avoir des
cochonneries de médicaments qui
circulent. Deuxième élément, c'est pas
celui qui a produit le médicament qui va
aller le proposer chez les malades en
gros
qui va aller le contrôler.
C'est pas lui qui contrôle. On est
d'accord. Il y a un vrai contrôle
indépendant. Mais deuxièmement, c'est
pas lui qui va le vendre directement aux
malades. Il y a des gens qui s'appellent
les médecins et et qui tousent touchent
pas une commission sur ce qu'il vendent
comme médicament. Non non, il touche pas
une commission. En gros, ils ont ils ont
qui leur dit "Tu vas faire de ton mieux
pour
pas des voyages au Maldives ?" Non, les
Non, certains.
Non, mais qui a des débordements ?
Regardons comment fonctionne globalement
un bon système de santé. Alors, on on on
fait le parallèle avec le système de
santé,
les agences de notation, ce qui ça c'est
un petit peu le le contrôle de
médicament, non ? Est-ce que les agences
de notation
font correctement leur travail ?
Pourquoi on a vu des agences de notation
chinoises débarquer maintenant qui
donnent qui délivrent pas les mêmes
notes que nos agences de notation
occidentale ?
C'est pas Christophe, les agences de
notation, est-ce que ça vaut le coup ?
Ça vaut pas le coup ? Est-ce que c'est
pas un petit peu de la bobologie pour
état ? Est-ce que c'est quoi ? Non, les
agences de notation, elles ont été
créées parce qu'il y avait un réel
besoin de mutualiser l'analyse de risqu
notamment de crédit sur les emprunts
obligataires.
Donc c'est le monde des investisseurs
qui plutôt qu'à chaque fois qu'il
regarde une obligation, fasse une
analyse de crédit poussé, bah regarde
quel est le rating. Il y a des notations
qui sont payées. Alors ça c'est un autre
problème de conflit d'intérêt par les
émetteurs eux-mêmes.
Mais l'investisseur lui paye un
abonnement. Pardon ?
C'est là où je voulais en venir.
Oui. Bah ça des conflits d'intérêt, il y
en a beaucoup partout hein. Je veux dire
les auditeurs, les commissaires au
compte sont payés par l'entreprise.
Bon donc parfois leur indépendance
peut-être
remise en cause.
Jérôme ?
Ouais. Je pense que c'est c'est
l'utilité sociale des agences de
notation n'est pas prouvée. Euh leur
seule excuse, c'est que c'est quand même
dans le monde de la finance des petits
animaux. Euh pour moi, le conflit
d'intérêt, il est beaucoup plus grave
que ça. Il est il est du côté de la
banque et du fait que quelqu'un gagne
d'autant plus d'argent que la personne
en face de lui va s'endetter.
Et il y a une deuxième chose qui est
choquante, mais on a oublié de le voir
que c'est choquant, c'est que plus je
suis malade, plus je vais payer cher mon
médicament. C'està dire plus je suis un
animal fragile, plus je vais payer mon
crédit en pourcentage cher. C'est
devenu, ça paraît logique à tout le
monde aujourd'hui, mais en fait c'est
profondément malsin. Si on fait le
parallèle avec la santé, ça revient à
dire euh parce que je suis pas
blanc-bleu, je commence à être un peu
âgé, je fatigué, j'ai mal au rein et
cetera et cetera. Je vais payer beaucoup
plus cher mes médicaments. Non, je paye
ma cotisation de sécurité sociale comme
tout le monde et il y a une
mutualisation du risque derrière. Et
donc le le vrai conflit d'intérêt, il
est que celui qui me propose le crédit
va toucher une commission sur ce crédit
et que plus je serai fragile, plus il me
fera payer cher.
Christophe, est-ce que c'est une
sélection darwinienne ? Oui, assez. Mais
tu vas payer plus cher parce que le
risque est plus important. Faut pas
oublier on et et disons
pourquoi c'est moi qui le supporte ? En
gros ma sécur ma cotisation de sécurité
sociale ne dépend pas du fait que je
c'est parce que tu fais la l'analogie
avec la santé. Là on parle pas de on
parle de crédit, on parle une banque a
des dépôts qu'elle va reprêter à des
entreprises. Elle a une responsabilité
en tant qu'ancien banquier. C'est la
première chose qu'on m'apprenait à
l'époque de m'assurer que je pouvais
rembourser les dépôts. On oublie toutes
les déviances qu'il y a eu dans la
l'hyperfinanciarisation
euh des marchés depuis 30 ou 40 ans. Euh
comme ça d'un petit coup de baguette
magique. Non non, mais quand je dis on
l'oublie, c'est que avant cette
hyperfinanciarisation et les excès que
l'on a connu, il était normal lorsqu'un
débiteur était plus risqué de facturer
plus cher parce que le risque était plus
important qui est entre guillemets euh
LAADEGE, euh le fameux couple infernal
indissociable,
le couple risque rentabilité. Si le
risque est plus élevé, la rentabilité
exhentée à exigé doit être plus forte.
Ensuite, dans les faits, le risque
s'avère ou il s'avère pas et la
rentabilité peut-être zéro.
Sauf si je fais une mutualisation,
c'est d'une certaine manière, il y a des
tas d'assurances où tout le monde paye
le même prix et il y a une mutualisation
dans la tarification.
Pour pour le pour la santé, je suis tout
à fait d'accord. dans le cadre des
risques de crédit, c'est moins évident
surtout sur des plus petites entreprises
parce que tu as pas des risques
homogènes.
Oui, là je pensais surtout au prix obsè
que paye les gens les gens pauvres sur
le crédit et la consommation.
Ça, je suis tout à fait d'accord. Oui,
tout à fait. Et on pourrait parler Et on
pourrait parler là-dessus même des euh
des frais d'incidents.
Oui, mais c'est c'est dans nos têtes
dans nos têtes qu'en gros, on s'est
habitué à cette idée que c'est normal de
payer en fonction du risque et donc on
va matraquer les gens qui sont plus à
risque. Oui, mais ça c'est c'est un peu
accessoirement c'est aussi les plus
faibles et donc on ne se demande pas si
en fait dans la décision le fait qu'il
soit faible et que du coup on peut les
taxer un peu plus n'entre pas autant
dans la décision que l'élément. pas la
même chose que l'univers des
entreprises. Là où je suis d'accord,
c'est qu'effectivement ce sont les gens
qui sont disons le plus dans la panade à
qui on enfonce
enfonce le mieux.
Non mais on on leur enfonce encore plus
la tête sous l'eau, ce qui est
moralement
inexcusable.
Et effectivement les banques françaises
mais pas que ont gagné beaucoup d'argent
sur ces frais et d'incidents. Au fil du
temps, on est en train de la le
régulateur est en train de d'essayer de
mettre du bon ordre. À l'échelle macro,
on a fait la même chose par exemple plus
proche de chez nous avec la Grèce.
À l'échelle macro, on fait la même chose
avec l'Afrique.
Tout se passe bien.
Et et on voit que ça peut être très
brutal un crédit. C'est-à-dire le moment
où on réveille en disant "Ben non, c'est
fini de jouer. Euh mais attention, si je
peux me permettre,
admettons que je sois une banque ou même
un particulier, c'est mon argent. Et mon
argent, j'ai la possibilité entre le
mettre ici ou là."
Et dans un cas, j'ai un risque plus
important que dans l'autre. Moi, je fais
un choix, mon argent, je le mets ici ou
là avec un taux de rentabilité espéré
qui est fonction du risque. C'est c'est
mon libre choix. Oui.
Et je peux me tromper.
Sauf qu'aujourd'hui dans l'économie
française, moi qui suis particulier, si
je veux mettre mon argent dans un
endroit complètement sûr comme la banque
centrale, je peux pas. Et donc j'ai pas
vraiment une lisibilité pour avec des
gens qui viendraient me dire "Chez moi
ça va rapporter ça, chez moi ça va
rapporter ça." C'est pas vrai que j'ai
ce choix du risque. Aujourd'hui, je suis
collé à aller des chez des
intermédiaires financiers.
Non, tu as le livret et tu as la bourse.
Oui,
mais je ne dis pas qu'il faudrait
investir en bourse actuellement.
On va on va on va juste mettre une
petite batterie. Donc si vous entendez,
on a on a une une caméra qui a un
problème de batterie. Ne vous inquiétez
pas, ça va revenir dans pas très
longtemps. Revenons sur nos nos petits
problèmes financiers.
Comment ça va se passer la prochaine
crise pour le Pékin lambda ? Alors le
Pékin Landa, c'est nous.
Alors l'État va débarquer en disant
"Vous inquiétez pas les gars, on est là,
on a des copains partout, on va vous
mettre de l'argent, on va sauver les
banques." Est-ce que les États peuvent
encore sauver les banques
sur le papier ? Non. Euh c'est pour ça
que c'était la BCE qui s'y était collée,
hein. Bon, alors qu'est-ce que pourrait
éventuellement faire les États ? Euh je
vais employer un mot que certains
considéraient comme un gros mot. Moi,
j'ai démarré ma carrière bancaire il y a
fort longtemps, il y a 40 ans, dans une
banque qui était nationalisée à
l'époque. Donc qu'est-ce que peut faire
l'État éventuellement ? C'est
nationaliser les établissements de
crédit qui sont défaillants,
c'est-à-dire mutualiser les pertes.
Pas obligatoirement, non. Mutualiser les
pertes, c'est quand vous injectez de
l'argent au niveau de l'État ou du
contribuable sans devenir propriétaire
de la banque. À ce moment-là, bah vous
avez que le downside, vous avez pas
l'upside. Si vous nationalisez par la
suite, bah ça peut beaucoup mieux
fonctionner. Donc c'est c'est c'est
différent. la nationalisation, les
actionnaires sont rincés
alors que en 2007-2008,
les soutien des États sous forme de
caution, voire quelques augmentations de
capital marginal, ça n'a pas rincé les
actionnaires. Alors, le cours de bourse
de ces banques a quand même souffert et
n'est pas encore revenu au au point haut
de d'avant la crise. Alors
le prix des actions bancaires,
elles se sont toutes vautré le les
bancaires, sauf une.
Sauf une ?
Ouais.
Laquelle ? Pardon ?
C'est pas celle qui a créé les CDS ?
Non.
JP Morgan ?
Oui. Oui. Mais fa sauf une, ça dépend
sur quelle période. Si on regarde sur
les banques européennes par rapport au
point haut de 2007 avant donc les
événements d'août 2007, globalement le
secteur non mais globalement le secteur
européen est le secteur enfin les cours
de bourse des banques européennes est à
90 % en dessous du niveau haut de 2007.
Ah oui, c'est et par rapport à l'actif
net. Et par rapport à l'actif net, bah
l'actif net en moyenne aujourd'hui pour
les banques européennes se trimbal aux
alentours de 06.
Ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire que
quand on compare l'actif net, les fonds
propres par action au bilan et le cours
de bourse, bah le 1 € qui est au bilan
n'est valorisé en bourse que 0 pour 60
centimes d'euros 0,6. Et ça dit la même
chose que les taux d'intérêt négatif.
C'est-à-dire qu'en gros, les
actionnaires qui ont quand même eu des
bien des malheurs sur les 40 dernières
années avec les banque euh n'ont
absolument pas confiance quand on leur
dit "La banque est solide, il peut rien
lui arriver, elle fait du 12 % sur fond
propre." C'est c'est lié au fait, c'est
que la rentabilité des banques ne s'est
pas rétablie depuis 2007 et que le coût
du capital, donc le taux de rentabilité
exigé par bah les actionnaires
euh est supérieur à la rentabilité des
fonds propres des banques. Donc
mécaniquement, euh on a un actif net qui
est en dessous.
Jérôme, j'aimerais qu'on parle du cours.
J'aimerais qu'on parle des inégalités.
H
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire à l'heure
actuelle ? Est-ce que le système
bancaire favorise les inégalités ?
Est-ce que ça s'est toujours comporté
comme ça ? Est-ce que Ah, j'ai avant ça,
ça remonte un quand la dernière fois
qu'on a eu des taux des taux négatifs ?
Autant que je sache jamais.
En France, il y en a jamais eu à ma
connaissance.
Et et dans le monde ?
Dans le monde jamais autant que je
sache, enfin, il y en a eu en Suisse
avant que ça démarre avec le le
l'assouplissement quantitatif en 2015.
décourager les placements. Oui,
non, normalement c'est ça n'existe pas.
Enfin, on peut ouvrir des livres
d'économie, des manuels d'économie
a 5 ans, il y a 10 ans, il y a 20 ans,
il y a 30 ans. Il y aura jamais un
chapitre sur les taux d'intérêt négatif.
Donc c'est-à-dire que on vit une une
situation qui n'a jamais été
expérimentée
tout à fait
avec des gens qui n'ont jamais piloté ce
type de de processus.
Ils sont dans un territoire totalement
inconnu avec pour pour être trivial, on
est assis sur une poudrière là. Non,
mais peut-être peut-être pas. Ce qui ce
qui est frappant, c'est je trouve c'est
qu'en gros
personne ne prend l'air inquiet,
surpris, se gratter la tête. Tout le
monde a l'air de dire business as usual.
Bah oui, bah il y avait + 1, 0 - 1, tout
ça c'est une échelle continue. Vous avez
appris ça en arithmétique hein, les
chiffres négatifs. Et et c'est ça qui
est inquiétant, c'est que à un moment
donné pour être un bon
un bon gestionnaire de risque, il faut
montrer qu'on est capable de de
s'inquiéter, de se poser des questions,
de s'interroger, de se demander mais
mais est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a pas
quelque chose de grave comme message
derrière ça ? et on entend rien silence
absolu, je trouve là-dessus aujourd'hui.
Avant de revenir sur les inégalités, je
voudrais qu'on parle écologie et on a
fait récemment une
une émission avec un prix Nobel qui
n'était pas Stiglitz mais qui était Jean
Jusel.
Est-ce que le capitalisme, est-ce que la
finance
va pas tuer l'écologie ou est-ce que
l'écologie va survivre
à cette croissance exponentielle ?
Christophe
moi
raconte un peu.
C'est un sujet difficile. Je dois
reconnaître que je ne suis pas un grand
expert du sujet. Donc
on se défausse pas comme ça.
BM
donc non c'est pas une question de BFM
TV. Je préfère m'exprimer habituellement
sur des sujets que je maîtrise pour
avoir une certaine valeur ajoutée. Bon,
alors pour quand même un peu répondre,
c'est on a un défi effectivement
climatique qui est monstrueux.
Est-ce que on va arriver
ou pas à financer cette transition
énergétique ? C'est la question qui se
pose. Est-ce que l'on pourrait je
tendance à dire sur le papier, on peut
toujours hein where there is a will,
there is a way. Donc des moments où il y
a une volonté, il y a un chemin.
Il y a un chemin. Bon, c'est pas moi, ça
doit être monsieur Lénine qui l'avait
formulé ainsi.
Puis il avait dit autre chose. Il avait
dit travail travail travail.
Ah bon ? C'est trois règles. Travail
travail travail. C'est comme location
location location dans l'immobilier qui
est la localisation.
Euh donc je ne pense pas que ce soit
impossible. Euh maintenant effectivement
faut peut-être changer le logiciel euh
de beaucoup de gens euh pour dire bon
ben ok maintenant cet argent au lieu
qu'il soit dans le système le manège
enchanté des LTR de l'assouplissement
quantitatif qui se retrouve à la banque
centrale ou qui se retrouve dans le
financement d'activités un peu stériles
comme l'immobilier résidentiel. Je vais
encore me faire des amis.
Ça pourrait être fléché ce qu'envisage
de faire disons la Commission européenne
fléché vers des investissements
structurel long terme sur ce r
les ver les brandes c'est ça
oui. Est-ce que ça pourrait ? C'est ça
la question. C'estàd pour moi finance
verte est un oxyor. C'est-à-dire que ça
ça peut pas ça peut pas voler. À un
moment donné, on a un système où on a
délégué le crédit à des banques.
Une des dimensions du problème
écologique et du réchauffement, c'est
pas la seule, mais une des dimensions,
c'est de dire il faut qu'on mette
pendant peu de temps énormément d'argent
sur des choses qui aujourd'hui ne sont
pas financées.
Donc il faut qu'il y ait quelque part un
levier. Oui, mais ce levier dans un
système où on et ce qui est frappant,
c'est qu'en ce moment, on déverse des
tomb d'argent. Donc si on regarde sur
les 10 dernières années, la collectivité
humaine a été capable de déverser des
tomb d'argent. Simplement, elle a bâti
une tuyoterie qui fait que tous ces
gens, y compris la banque centrale
européenne, ils savent libérer des
milliards et des milliards, des milliers
de milliards comme tu le disais tout à
l'heure. Simplement, ils savent pas du
tout ce que ça va donner. Hm.
Ça va arroser en plus fine les banques
et ensuite vont faire "Ah ben ça, on
sait pas monsieur ce qu'elle va faire."
Et moi, quelque chose qui fait que je
sais déjà que ça marchera pas, c'est je
lisais euh un article où on expliquait
que un certain nombre de financiers ont
une idée géniale, c'est que avec la
fonte du Groenland, on va pouvoir
récupérer tout ce qu'il y a dans le
sous-sol du Groenland
avec B. C'est vrai, on sait qu'il y a du
pétrole, on sait qu'il y a mais le
problème c'est qu'il y a 7 km de glace
au-dessus donc c'est inexploitable.
Aujourd'hui l'un des dossiers chauds,
alors on peut même dire que c'est ça qui
a réveillé la petite Trump quelque part,
l'un des dossiers chauds dans le monde
de la finance, c'est de se dire comment
est-ce qu'on va pouvoir investir pour
quand il y aura eu la fonte du
Groenland. Et la fonte du Groenland,
c'est le grand le grand débat en ce
moment de se dire est-ce qu'on n'est pas
au cliquet qui pourrait déclencher la
fonte du Groenland ? Là, c'est pas 1 m
de plus des eau, c'est 10 m de plus des
eaux m
ou 20 m. En fait, c'est en dehors de ce
qu'on imagine aujourd'hui. C'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui pour qu'il faut qu'il y
ait will. Yes. Mais il faut qu'il y ait
derrière un instrument. C'estàd il faut
que la collectivité le jour où elle a
une volonté et un instrument pour
appliquer cette volonté. Et tant qu'on
dira la finance, la tuyauterie de la
finance a été déléguée à des grosses
banques, il y a aucune chance que ça
marche. C'est impossible.
Non mais c'est génial la fonte du
Groenland. Regarde, on va exploiter le
Groenland, on va virer les inuites,
ensuite on va investir dans des boîtes
de sécurité pour aller tabasser les
petits migrants écologiques. On va
construire des centres de ration
administratif,
des p d'air, on va on va remonter. Mais
il y a des tas de gens qui travaillent
là-dessus en se disant aujourd'hui la
part des fonds propres des enf connaît
tout ça mieux que moi mais aujourd'hui
une grande partie des des bilans des
sociétés pétrolières est faux puisque ou
alors ça veut dire qu'il y aura le on
aura 10 m 10 m au-dessus de l'Arc de
Triomphe d'eau. Comme le window dressing
des banques. Non
non mais c'est qu'en gros on fait
semblant de croire qu'on va tirer tout
le pétrole qu'on a sur terre. En même
temps, on signe des accords en disant
"Non, non, on va pas le on va pas le
tirer ce pétrole. rassurez-vous. Et donc
à un moment donné, je crois que une
partie des gens ne sont pas dupes du
fait qu'en effet, ils n'y croient pas et
il n'y croi pas avec leur billet de
banque et ça a plus de poids aujourd'hui
que tout ce qu'on peut faire comme
grande déclaration. Alors Christophe,
l'écologie ça mais l'écologie là-dessus
enfin je reviens moi sur mon histoire de
Will et de Way
des banc où mais il faut qu'il ait la
volonté politique. Tu parles de levier,
mais le levier ça peut très bien être au
travers de la banque centrale voire même
de la régulation où tu as le levier en
terme de fléchage de de liquidité ou
oublie la situation actuelle et soyons
regardons devant où une partie de ces
liquidités peut-être fléchée vers des
investissements de long terme parce que
ces investissements là effectivement
rentabilité à court terme très faible.
Bon, d'un autre côté, je crois qu'il
faut vraiment le faire puisque à la
limite, c'est quand même une question de
survie de la planète, même si je suis
pas un collapsologue. Euh, on voit bien
qu'on a quand même un gros testicule
dans dans la soupe là, hein. Donc, il
faut il faut s'occuper de de ce
problème-là. Est-ce qu'on va y arriver ?
Moi, c'est tout à l'heure, tu disais que
tu étais un peu utopiste. Disons que sur
ce planlà, j'espère être un peu plus
optimiste.
Non, mais je me suis mal exprimé. Je dis
pas qu'on va pas y arriver. Ce que je
veux dire, c'est qu'on ne peut pas y
arriver à moins de changer profondément.
Oui, il faut changer le logiciel
les tuyoteries parce que les tuyoteries
ne peuvent pas permettre d'y arriver. Et
il vaut mieux le dire clairement que
faire semblant de croire qu'à un moment
donné, comme on parle encore que de
2050, ça va bien se passer, vous allez
voir.
Alors le wishful thinking, le le
la danse incantatoire qu'on va on va
changer le système,
ça a pas l'air de se passer là. Vous
vous rendez compte ? notre intelligencia
bancaire et politique. D'ailleurs, les
politiques sont financées par les
banques. Quand vous regardez qui détient
la dette part, c'est que il y a beaucoup
de banques quand même. Et puis quand il
y a un parti politique Oui. Non, mais
quand il y a un parti politique,
fait le crédit, c'est
quand il y a un parti politique, on va
pas prendre la défense du Front
National,
mais le le Front National peut pas se
financer. Donc c'est une façon aussi
d'avoir un gros poids le crédit. La
question que je me pose, c'est sur ce
changement de logiciel,
c'est pas trop tard. On n pas trop notre
intelligent bancaire et politique est
tellement
dopé, drogué à ce système, ils vont
jamais lâcher.
Ils vont jamais lâcher.
J'ai toujours le parallèle en 1788. On
imagine, il y a la caméra, on est là et
on dit il y a des gens qui ont tout, ils
ont tous les privilèges et cetera. Tu
sais comment ça s'est terminé, hein ?
Oui. Et ben aujourd'hui, il y a dans une
peut-être pas une majorité de pays du
monde, mais un certain nombre de pays du
monde, il y a la démocratie politique
qui est qui est un abandon total par
rapport au système qui existait avant.
Donc l'humanité est parfaitement
capable. Elle a certains jeux qui ont
l'air de marcher. Elle est capable pour
changer pour d'autres jeux qui marchent
mieux parce que parce qu'on a plus
plaisir à jouer à ces jeux-là qu'au jeux
d'avant. Aujourd'hui, on a un jeu euh
économique qui dans beaucoup de domaines
est beaucoup moins satisfaisant que le
jeu politique. En gros, on est encore au
stade de l'aristocratie ou au mieux du
suffrage sensitaire. Euh donc le si les
hommes ont été capables de de d'inventer
la démocratie, il y aura peut-être
quelques têtes coupées, mais il y a
aussi des beaux des beaux gestes. La
nuit du 4 août, la nuit du 4 août, il y
avait un certain nombre il y avait un
certain nombre d'aristocrates qui
étaient dans la salle du jeu de paume.
Et et je suis persuadé quand on dit on
parlait tu disais tout à l'heure
l'inégalité, on voit des des
milliardaires qui disent qui qui sont
l'équivalent des nobles qui étaient dans
la salle et qui disent "Moi, je suis
prêt à me couper un bras, c'est-à-dire à
abandonner une partie de mes richesses
pour que le système change."
Donc à un moment donné, oui, on est sur
des systèmes de changement de pouvoir,
de changement de braquet. On a quand
même un levier pour moi qui est le
levier politique et et est-ce qu'on
arrivera à trouver des hommes politiques
qui auront la vision de euh réconcilier
euh réconcilier peut-être pas tout le
monde parce qu'il restera peut-être
Bernard Arnaud dans un coin ou je sais
pas qui, mais réconcilier presque tout
le monde sur le fait qu'on peut inventer
une économie qui sera beaucoup plus
agréable à jouer pour tout le monde,
pour presque tout le monde.
Christophe, tu veux ajouter un mot
là-dessus ?
Non. Non. Alors, on va parler euh
de ce qui s'est passé aux États-Unis
avec les les injections de la Fed comme
ça. Alors là maintenant, ils vont monter
à 1200 milliards.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi le la la Fed nous
injecté
1200 milliards pardon ?
Ouais. La totalité de leur plan, c'est
les 1200.
Ah bon ? Sur le marché des ripos. Ah bon
? OK. Moi, j'en étais resté à 300
milliards, mais ce qui était déjà pas
mal. Euh qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire
là-dessus ? Ben c'est quand on parle de
tuyauterie sur le marché des ripos, il y
a eu manifestement
C'est quoi un repos ?
Alors un repos, ce qu'on appelle la
pension livrée euh c'est un outil qui
permet à une banque de se refinancer sur
le marché monétaire ou interbancaire de
façon sécurisée. Comme les banques n'ont
plus tellement confiance entre elles
depuis la crise de 2007-2008,
pour se refinancer, elles vont proposer
un collatéral, donc une garantie, une
sûreté réelle. contre de l'argent. Bon,
alors typiquement le ripo le plus
classique c'est on va se financer au
jour le jour auprès d'une autre banque
en lui donnant en collatéral un emprunt
d'état par exemple à Noat pour la France
ou le Tibonde américain à 30 ans pour
les États-Unis. Donc c'est ça le
mécanisme, c'est un financement court
terme du marché monétaire sécurisé. Bon,
qui s'est fort développé après la crise
parce que justement on ne voulait plus,
les banques ne voulaient plus se faire
du crédit en blanc, voire même du coup
elle passait par la banque centrale où
elle faisait des dépôts qui étaient
reprêtés et la banque centrale devenait
de facto le marché interbancaire. Alors
le problème qu'il a eu donc qui a
démarré maintenant il y a quoi une
quinzaine de jours maintenant euh c'est
de l'ordre donc moi j'étais resté à 300
milliards de de dollars. Je vais donner
deux chiffres pour qu'effectivement on
réalise bien que ça n'est pas anodin
euh au moment des attentats du 11
septembre 2001.
Euh à ce moment-là, par exemple, la BCE
a injecté
euh 60 milliards d'euros dans le système
bancaire européen pour éviter que
justement il y a une crise de trésorerie
et un effondrement. Bon, le 9 août 2007
qui est en fait le début de la crise
2007-2008,
alors on dit toujours ce sont ces
cowboys d'Américains qui nous ont
exporté leur crise des stop primes.
Ouais, d'accord. Il y a quand même des
gérants français qui avaient fouré des
cy caves monétaires dynamiques.
Normalement une cav monétaire c'est sans
risque. Moi je les appelle cavétaire
dynamité où on avait mis des poches de
subprime. Bon et se trouve que c'était
trois grands établissements.
Donc il y avait quoi ? Il y avait la BNP
BNP Paris-bas au plus petit et puis AXA.
Bon à ce moment-là le 9 août 2007
l'injection de la BCE était de 90
milliards d'euros. Bon euh au moment de
la crise euh disons euh la plus
importante à l'automne 2008,
on disait à ce moment-là que il manquait
dans la liquidité du système bancaire
européen 600 milliards d'euros. Bon, je
n'ai plus en tête les chiffres de
liquidité injecté à la même époque qu'en
2008 par la euh banque centrale
américaine, par la Fed. Je les ai plus
en tête, mais c'était euh euh
sensiblement au-delà de 1000 milliards
de dollars et notamment, parce que ça
aussi il faut quand même le rappeler,
dont une grosse partie était utilisée
par les banques européennes plus que les
banques américaines. Alors, les 300
milliards là, ça prouve quand même qu'il
y a un problème dans le système parce
que normalement, on devrait pas avoir un
accident de plomberie comme ça. Je
dirais surtout de nos jours.
Alors, le le problème c'est quoi ?
C'est-à-dire que les collates sont
tellement pourries qu'on est obligé de
passer par la Fed pour pouvoir garantir
tout ce petit micmac. Alors, je sais pas
si c'est les colates qui sont pourris ou
si on est en absence de colate.
C'est-à-dire que avec la politique
monétaire de l'assouplissement
quantitatif, qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait la
BCE ? Elle achète des empreints d'État.
Bon ben, tout empreint d'État qui se
retrouve au bilan de la BCE ne peut plus
circuler dans le marché des ripos. Donc
on a peut-être un facteur comme ça,
c'est de d'assèchement du colate pour
bien faire fonctionner ce système. Il
peut y avoir aussi d'autres effets
pervers parce qu'on dit toujours le ripo
c'est très bien, c'est un financement
sécurisé. Ouais, mais c'est une épée à
double tranchant euh en ce sens que euh
quand on a ce financement sécurisé, euh
la banque qui euh prend en pension
livrée sur 24 heures ou sur un mois un
emprunt d'état va pas vous financer 100
% de cet emprunt d'état. Il va mettre ce
qu'on appelle un aircut, c'est-à-dire il
va financer, admettons, un aircut de 3
%, 97 % du montant. Bon,
si le aircut augmente
parce que par exemple l'emprunt d'État
euh c'est ce qui était arrivé avec
l'Italie en 2011 ou en 2012, euh si le
rating la notation financière de
l'Italie diminue, le Aircode qui va être
demandé sur le marché ne sera plus de 3
% mais admettons de 6 %. Et dans ces
cas-là, ça a un impact négatif parce que
ça peut forcer des ventes liquidatives
de ses ripos. Donc ça c'est un premier
problème. Le 2e problème, toujours dans
la plomberie euh c'est que on a un
mécanisme qui s'appelle la réhypothéc.
La réhypothéc
entre une banque A et une banque B peut
donner lieu à un autre riot d'une banque
B avec une banque C, d'une banque C avec
une banque D. Et on sait qu'en moyenne
sur le marché des ripos, cette
réhypothéc
l'ordre de 2,5 fois. Donc un ripo deux
fois et demi tourne. Si dans cette
chaîne il y en a un qui cale, c'est un
bordel noir. C'est un plat de spaghetti
qu'il faut essayer de désmêler.
Est-ce que je ne sais pas dans le cadre
des 200 milliards qui ont été injectés,
est-ce que c'est lié à un problème
sur le marché des Ripo avec un acteur
qui entre guillemets a toussé très fort
? possible
comme une grosse banque.
Ça serait plutôt une grosse banque. Mais
je ne sais pas est-ce qu'on peut quand
même se dire pour pas toujours être
totalement noir,
c'est pas être noir, c'est pragmatique.
Oui, je suis très pragmatique et j'ai
toujours été plutôt sévère avec les
banques. Donc j'ai on peut pas me
m'accuser de laxisme par rapport par
rapport à elle.
Je crois que si ça avait été dans ce cas
d'espèce une banque, comme ça fait
maintenant 3 semaines, on aurait un nom.
On se connaît
ça ça ça circule assez vite. On a
toujours rien
énorme entre les banques.
On a toujours rien. Donc c'est pas
obligatoirement ça ou une grosse banque.
Bon alors l'autre chose que je dois
quand même dire c'est que dans le cadre
d'un d'un dîner en ville quand on va
dîner en ville sauf que ce dîner en
ville au moment de ces événements
c'était à la campagne mais ça s'est
fortuiti. Il y avait un un grand
régulateur français dont je terra le nom
qui avec qui j'ai un peu discuté dans le
cadre de ce dîner et
qui s'appelle comment ?
Non
et qui
était également surprisons des
explications données par la Fed. À
l'époque, il y avait trois explications
qui ne lui paraissaient pas cohérentes,
qui ne me paraissaient pas non plus
cohérentes. Voilà, à ce stade, c'est
tout ce qu'on peut dire. On peut pas non
plus affabuler
Jérôme euh est-ce que c'est une question
d'internet, je vais je vais la
reformuler un petit peu. Est-ce que la
plebe est-ce que le public est
suffisamment informé de ça ? Est-ce que
le le discours autour de la finance
n'est pas complexifié à dessin pour
enfumer tout le monde ? Est-ce que
ceux qui ont la tête dans le guidon,
dans les entreprises pour payer leurs
taxes, pour aller bosser, pour aller
chercher les enfants à l'école et ont
trop délégué leur compréhension du
système financier, est-ce que
ben je pense qu'une partie
la presse financière fait joue son rôle
d'une certaine manière. le le le ce que
tu décris, c'est-à-dire le fait que euh
le système est rendu encore plus
complexe qu'il est. Euh c'est très très
vrai. C'est pour ça qu'il y a des
bouquins pour euh apprendre la la
finance au nul. Euh je pense que c'est
très lourd d'une certaine manière, c'est
aussi une protection parce que ça
rassure le métier de banquier est un peu
stressant quand même. Faut faut
reconnaître à un moment donné, ils ont
tous les torts peut-être, mais enfin
c'est un métier c'est un métier
stressant.
que j'ai adoré mais c'était avant les
dérives. Voilà,
c'estàdire pas de [__] pas de cque.
Oui. Voilà. Donc dans un métier
stressant, on a besoin de se rassurer.
Et donc parler tous le même jargon un
peu incompréhensible, c'est vrai que
c'est voilà, il y a un peu ça dans
l'armée aussi ça. Voilà, ça crée un
esprit de corps. Donc OK, si c'était que
ça d'une certaine manière, ce serait pas
très grave.
C'est là où ça devient extrêmement
grave, c'est plus que ça impressionne à
la fois les gens de la rue mais les
politiques. À un moment donné, on va pas
demander à à tous les Français euh
d'avoir un 3e cycle de finances ou alors
c'est très inquiétant que fait la enfin
on n'est plus en démocratie. Si à un
moment donné il faut avoir un 3è cycle
en nucléaire ou un 3è cycle en finance
pour arriver à comprendre comment ça
marche, on n'est plus en démocratie. à
un moment donné, on délègue,
c'est-à-dire qu'on dit "Moi, j'ai pas le
temps puis ça m'ennuie, mais j'espère
que celui pour qui j'ai voté, lui il va
comprendre et lui il va il va leur
mettre les points sur les i et ce qui ce
qui est effrayant, je trouve, c'est à
quel point ça marche vis-à-vis des
autorités politiques." Et c'est ça qui
pour moi est est la la vraie démission
de la démocratie. le le politique par
rapport à ces problèmes donc financiers
de crise financière, de régulation
par rapport au lobby, le lobby
surpuissant que quand même j'ai bien
fréquenté à Bruxelles a toujours eu
tendance à dire aux politiques "C'est
trop compliqué, c'est touchez pas, vous
allez casser."
Le rôle du politique devrait de être de
leur dire "Attendez, je comprends pas
très bien, on va simplifier les choses
et donc vous me réexpliquez. tant que je
comprends pas, on fait pas et sinon on
simplifie les choses. La
complexification du secteur financier
sur les 40 dernières années, peu
importe, c'est comme je l'ai dit en
fait, c'est c'est un peu la résultante
de la chute du mur de Berlin où on a eu
ce mouvement de néolibéralisme, de
dérégulation financière et et derrière
cela des produits dérivés entre autres.
J'ai codémarré l'activité des produits
dérivés d'une petite banque française en
83. Donc ça date pas ça date pas d'hier.
Euh des produits dérivés dont on peut
parler euh en détail qui ne servent pas
toujours à grand-chose hein. 90 % des
volumes euh sur le marché des des
dérivés est entre institution
financière. il n'y a que 10 % des
volumes euh qui sont pour des
utilisateurs finaux, on va dire des
entreprises parce que les produits
dérivés, il y en a qui sont légit comme
on dit, euh sont là pour couvrir un
risque de l'entreprise, ce soit un
risque de taux d'intérêt, un risque de
change, un risque sur le prix d'une
matière première, ce genre de choses.
Alors moi, je dis toujours quand on
commence à complexifier quelque chose,
que ça veut dire on commence à mettre un
para avance, c'est qu'il y a un péché
qui est commis derrière. Bon, et sur le
marché des des dérivés, mais également
sur d'autres domaines, c'est très
nettement ce que l'on a vu euh ces
dernières décennies avec cette
financiarisation
assez euh effrainée,
morbide. Oui, parce que en fait la la
le problème et on retombe sur le
problème des banques trop grosses, c'est
qu'à un moment donné, quand vous êtes
dans un métier relativement simple, on
peut l'expliquer et on peut l'expliquer
du haut en bas de la hiérarchie et à un
moment donné, s'il y a un régulateur qui
arrive, on va aussi pouvoir lui
expliquer. À partir de vous avez des
moments où on a un animal monstrueux qui
fait absolument n'importe quoi, on est
obligé d'inventer un jargon, ce qu'on
appelle la mesure du risque, la value at
risque, tous ces instruments qui font
que on dit "OK, vous avez 50000 métiers
qui ont rien à voir, mais on va mettre
la même mesure sur tous ces métiers."
Et brusquement,
ça évite au patron d'avoir à comprendre
ce qu'on fait dans les soutes. Puisque
savoir qu'en gros les gens ils
sécurisent je sais pas quoi de sur de
l'immobilier, des gros tickets
d'immobilier, c'est pas important.
Qu'est-ce que c'est en en valueque ?
Combien ça pèse au bilan ? Et d'une
certaine manière, cette espèce
d'espérantau des banquiers
est aussi un voile entre la réalité et
eux. et et plus ils sont dans le jargon,
plus il faut se dire ils comprennent pas
vraiment ce qui se passe. Il ne parle
plus de la réalité financière, il parle
de la mesure de la réalité financière.
Et donc c'est vrai que c'est un symptôme
effrayant ce jargon, mais il y a une
manière de le faire éclater, c'est que
si par exemple on dit "Vous avez pas
droit au jargon dans toutes les
commissions parlementaires, vous avez
les commissions de régulation de la
banque n'ont plus de banquiers en leur
sein comme on dit qu'il faut plus et ben
à un moment donné il faut qu'un esprit
normal puisse arriver à comprendre.
Malheureusement, on n'en prend pas ce
chemin parce que je rappelle que a été
nommé comme patron de l'autorité
bancaire européenne l'ancien chef
lobbyist d'une très grande banque
espagnole qui s'appelle Santander et le
directeur général de l'autorité bancaire
européenne que je connais assez bien
pour l'avoir côillé au collège
consultatif part chez les lobbyistes le
plus affreux des banques d'affaires qui
s'appelle l'afmé. Donc c'est là c'est
les revolving d'or dans les deux sens.
On a un lobby qui prend le contrôle de
l'autorité de régulation bancaire et on
a l'ancien régulateur qui va même s'il
dit qu'il va pas s'occuper des dossiers
de lobby hein, mais qui va quand même
chez le principal lobbyiste du secteur.
C'est quand même assez étonnant.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi affreux ?
Affreux quoi ? Le
le lobbyiste le plus affreux.
Alors mais quand je dis le plus affreux
en fait c'est le plus redoutable. Le
plus puissant disons
le plus redoutable.
et et le directeur général de l'autorité
bancaire européenne
part chez le lobbyiste
pour une rémunération qui va être de
l'ordre de sep fois supérieure à ce
qu'il touchait à la BE.
Fantastique.
Formidable.
Ça pose un problème de démocratie. Ah
oui oui oui oui et et assez facile.
Enfin après il y a des décisions qui
sont dures à prendre mais il y a pas
besoin d'avoir un cerveau immense pour
voir quelles sont les règles qui
permettent d'éviter ce genre de dérapage
et d'éviter l'entre soi. Et ce qui
exaspère le le simple citoyen, c'est
cette impression d'entre soi et
qui en effet se dégrade plutôt. Ou
ça passe crème hein. C'est ça ça passe
tout seul. hein, c'est magnifique.
Euh les certaines banques sont en train
de licencier un peu leur personnel. Je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué la HSBC.
Bon là, on en est à 40000 postes.
Euh c'est un signe, c'est pas un signe.
Ils sont en train de couper euh
l'hémorragie des salaires pour parce
qu'ils ils ont le couteau sous la gorge
avec les taux négatifs. Ils sont en
train de faire quoi ? De
l'automatisation de de choses comme ça.
Paraît-il qu'il va falloir qu'on paye
pour prendre rendez-vous avec notre
conseiller ? Ah bon ?
C'est possible ? Bah à ce moment-là, je
veux dire toutes les banques digitales
et les applis sur smartphone ont un bel
avenir de devant elle. Qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire là-dessus ? On peut dire deux
choses. C'est un pour celles d'entre
elles qui sont des banques universelles,
bah on voit bien que le modèle de
résilience ne fonctionne pas.
Et la deuxième chose que l'on peut dire
aussi, c'est que finalement, alors qui
suis-je pour les juger ? Mais tant pis,
je suis un analyste indépendant. Ça veut
quand même dire que pas mal disons de
ces dirigeants de très grosses banques
ont manqué de vision stratégique. On
sont juste cupid.
Bonfort
hein, c'est vrai que
non mais parce que on découvre en
que les clients euh utilisent plus
internet et viennent moins dans les
agences alors que jusqu'en 2015 ont
continué à ouvrir des agences. Là je
parle du marché français. Euh qu'est-ce
qu'on demande d'un dirigeant bancaire ?
C'est d'avoir une vision stratégique, il
est très largement rémunéré pour ça, qui
est d'essayer de voir au-dessus de la
colline colline. Ça veut dire anticiper.
Et là, manifestement, cette
digitalisation
et ces comportements des des clients qui
ont un peu fui les agences, ils ont pas
vu le le coup venir.
C'est qui est quand même bon
stratégique,
ça ne ça n'est pas porté à leur crédit
là ce coup-ci. Oui. Et puis d'une
certaine manière, si on regarde sur les
les 30 dernières années, les deux
secteurs de l'économie qui ont explosé
en taille en valeur ajoutée, donc en
salaire à la fin euh
le premier on là au coin de la tête,
c'est internet. Tout ce qui est autour
d'internet qui a absolument exposé, qui
a pris je crois quatre points de PIB
supplémentaires. Et le deuxième plus
inattendu, c'est la finance qui a aussi
explosé en terme de de PIB. Euh cette du
côté de l'électronique, je dis toujours,
on voit ce qu'on a, on aime ou on aime
pas, mais enfin l'internet existe, il a
changé un certain nombre de choses, y
compris pour les émissions télé. Euh
donc chacun d'entre nous a vu sa vie
changer par cela. Sur la finance, on
n'arrive pas à comprendre où est passé
tout cet argent qui est quand même notre
argent parce que c'est quatre points de
PIB. En plus euh cet argent qui tourne,
il y a des gens bien payés pour le faire
tourner mais c'est nous à la fin
l'économie réelle qui le payons.
Juste les quatre points de PIB, c'est
quatre points de PIB qui ont été faits
avec de la dette,
non ? Qui ont été faits avec
l'innovation financière, ça a été
largement fait sur la BFI avec
l'innovation financière qu'il y a eu
depuis 30 ans dans la finance. C'est
vrai qu'il y a eu une énorme innovation
financière dans la finance, mais
l'utilité est discutable. Moi, donne
l'utilité est nulle pour moi.
C'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné, voir
négative, si on demande à n'importe qui
autour de nous, qu'est-ce qui a changer
dans le service bancaire que tu reçois,
petit patron ou
salarié, qu'est-ce qui a changé vraiment
? Alors, on va dire, il y a les ATM, la
distribution, mais globalement le
service est le même.
Ouais, mais les frais banquiers ont
explosé. Non mais quelque part oui. La
qualité c'est
la qualité du service devient pire hein.
Je
pour la pour la banque de détail c'est
catastrophique.
Oui. Mais donc il y a quand même quelque
part disait il y a un blè parce que si
si on a quatre points de PIB en plus et
qu'on voit pas le service en face c'est
qu'on a une usine à gaz. Alors, je dis
que c'est pire que ça puisque l'usine à
gaz peut nous péter à la figure, mais on
a une usine à gaz
classer ces vaisseaux
qu'on paye et dont on voit pas à quoi
elle sert. Donc à un moment donné, mon
cœur mon cœur saigne évidemment chaque
fois qu'il y a des emplois qui
disparaissent. Euh c'est c'est voilà, il
y a il y a des problèmes humains
sûrement derrière, mais à la fin des
fins, je dis bonne nouvelle,
on doit récupérer ces quatre points de
PIB. Il n'y a aucune raison qu'on ait
cet impôt qui nous soit tombé dessus de
de toute cette innovation financière qui
servait à rien. Donc d'une certaine
manière, pour moi, c'est un retour à une
situation plus équilibrée. Quand quand
j'ai débuté ma carrière il y a 40 ans, à
ce moment-là, je suis devenu banquier
par hasard, mais j'ai adoré mon métier.
On disait que la banque c'était le
secteur de la sidérurgie.
rapport min rapport de monsieur à la
main qui est toujours là qui est
toujours là et qui continue à parler
d'ailleurs, continue à avoir un avis
surtout mais là c'est vrai que c'est
marrant, il avait annoncé il y a 40 ans
la fin de la banque et en fait ça ne
s'est pas réalisé comme ça parce que il
y a eu des lois de dérégulation et du
coup et cette financiarisation
résultante des lois de dérégulation la
finance a fait ça.
Mais aujourd'hui,
je crois que c'est vraiment la
sidérurgie,
le secteur bancaire traditionnel tel
qu'on le connaît. Donc c'est 40 ans plus
tard comme quoi parfois des prédictions
et des prévisions prennent beaucoup de
temps. La banque va avoir raison, la
banque va se voter.
Alors c'est pas alors voter, c'est en
cas de crise, oui, mais en tout cas qui
ait de plus en plus de réduction
d'effectif, d'attrition, ça c'est très
clair hein. au niveau européen, je crois
qu'il y a déjà par rapport au début de
crise et aujourd'hui, alors je suis plus
sûr du chiffre, mais il y a eu 400000
emplois euh en moins au niveau bancaire
européen. Bon euh sur la France là tout
ce qui a été annoncé, on parle de 50000
emplois en moins.
Une autre petite question, puis après on
va passer aux questions internet et puis
on va finir cette interview parce que ça
commence à faire un peu long. euh nos
nos commentateurs politiques, nos
chroniqueurs euh économiques, nos
chaînes d'information en continu
traitant de l'économie,
c'est pas un petit peu du c'est pas un
peu des bullshiters,
il brassent pas de l'air chaud, il nous
sculpte pas de la fumée.
C'est pour toi ça ?
Ben je en gros
beaucoup n'osent pas en parler.
Euh un certain nombre euh sont quand
même un peu coincés parce que
aujourd'hui si vous voulez être bien
introduit dans le milieu bancaire, faut
quand même pas trop le prendre à rebosse
poil. Voilà, il faut voilà si on veut
une deuxième interview, il faut que la
première se soit bien passée. Donc on a
un problème de pouvoir mais qui se
retrouve pas que avec ce pouvoir là. À
la fin, on a l'un des principaux
pouvoirs économiques de de notre
hexagone
qui
fait que on le prend dans le sens du
poil. Il y a quand même eu quelques
émissions à la télévision qui étaient
pas mal faites sur j'en ai une en tête
sur BNP Paribas
qui était pas qui était assez assez
caustique quand même. Donc c'est lequel
? Mais c'était il y a un an émission à
laquelle je l'avais trouvé bien parce
que j'y avais participé évidemment
toi aussi mais mais voilà il
décortiquait bien le système BNP Paribas
notamment BNP Paribas suisse et il
faisait remarquer par exemple que il y
avait jamais eu la moindre action en
justice initiée en France contre BNP
Paribaas sur BNP Paribaas Suisse.
Voilà donc ça existe. C'est en train de
démarrer parce que il y a déjà des
poursuites légales qui ont été engagées
aux États-Unis contre BNP Paribas pour
avoir été un acteur alors c'était la
justice de trancher dans le financement
du génocide au Soudan
via le contournement de l'embargo
pétrolier américain. Et si j'ai bien
compris, j'ai lu ça dans la presse il y
a peu de temps. C'était peut-être pas en
France, c'est peut-être en Suisse que le
l'information a a percé. De temps à
autre, on trouve des informations à
l'étranger, pas chez nous. Euh comme
quoi, je crois qu'il y avait une plainte
qui était portée aussi enfin déposée en
France sur le même sujet.
Comment ça se fait qu'on trouve pas
l'information chez nous ?
Elle y était dans l'émission de BNP
Paribas, ils en parlaient he quand même
du Soudan parce que c'est un vieux
machin. Le problème c'est en gros que
c'est jamais été reçu en France. C'est
c'est qu'à un moment donné c'est un
secret de polichinel. Cette émission
montrait que c'était un secret de
Polichinel, qu'on avait une lessiveuse
king size en en Suisse et qui avait
jamais eu aucun procureur en France qui
s'était saisi de quoi que ce soit
là-dessus sur la fameuse amende pour
contournement d'embargot de 9 milliards
de dollars de juin 2014 qui est un
dossier que j'ai suivi de très près et
ensuite grâce on va dire à mes réseaux
professionnels euh j'avais les quelques
informations, on va dire en interne qui
était pas du délit d'initié puisque je
ne trais pas la l'action.
Pas mal d'informations
perlées dans la presse suisse alors que
ça considère ça concerné, excusez-moi,
BNP Paris-Bas suisse et pas dans la
France et pas en France.
une autocensure. Non, mais tu as raison
sur le si tu prends l'ensemble euh moi
je je signale quand même quelques
pépites parce que c'est vrai quand même
que quelques chaînes publiques ont eu le
courage de faire quelques émissions euh
là-dessus mais c'est vrai qu'il faut les
chercher un peu avec une loupe.
Euh on va parler trading sur les
matières premières alimentaires. C'est
bien, c'est pas bien.
On fait du blé un peu là-dessus. C'est
alors je dirais il y a deux choses. Il y
a le trading et l'investissement.
Le trading sur les matières premières
alimentaires, bah il en faut hein. C'est
comme sur tout marché, on doit pouvoir
éventuellement, excusez-moi, je perds ma
voix, se couvrir contre le risque de
variation de prise sur la matière
première. Ça ça a toujours existé hein.
Les premiers produits dérivés, c'était
sur les matières premières. Bon, ce qui
est différent, c'est que c'est créé une
nouvelle classe d'actifs pour des
investisseurs institutionnels du style
de des gérants d'actifs, des fonds de
pension et cetera qui ne font pas eux du
trading sur la matière première mais qui
investissent sur cette matière première
en espérant que le prix va augmenter
quand vous faites un investissement.
C'est ce que vous envisagez de faire. Le
problème c'est que c'est venu
déséquilibrer
le marché. On en a vu les conséquences
lamentables au moment de la crise de
2008, ce qu'on avait appelé al les
images, les gens les ont certainement
encore oublié, les émeutes de la fin
notamment en Égypte parce que on avait
fait monter le prix du blé de façon
stratosphérique. Donc mon point de vue
personnel, c'est que les matières
premières peuvent faire l'objet de
trading pour couvrir des risques
producteurs utilisateur final. En
revanche, avoir les matières premières
sauf l'ore qui est-ce que c'est une
matière première comme classe
d'investissement ? Euh je ne suis pas un
grand fan à titre personne.
Est-ce que le le marché de l'or a été
manipulé ?
C'est ce qu'on dit. Je suis pas un
spécialiste du marché de l'or.
Est-ce qu'il est facilement manipulable
?
C'est possible parce que vous avez pas
énormément d'acteurs. Là, je parle au
niveau du trading, on peut même se
demander si les banques centrales à un
moment donné l'ont pas un peu manipulé
aussi. Mais bon, mais le marché de l'UR
est un peu spécifique. C'est pas c'est
une classe à part, un actif stérile.
Mais
pourquoi les banques centrales auraient
manipulé le prix de ? Bah, dans certains
cas, à un moment donné, comme elles
étaient toutes vendeuses d'or,
maintenant, elles rachètent comme des
bêtes de l'or. Euh, elles voulaient pas
que le prix euh chute trop rapidement.
Alors que maintenant sont dans un
mouvement inverse qui est de on
réembarque de l'or parce que là aussi
dans les choses peu importe l'or mais
l'or c'est cette relique barbare comme
disait Kanes ça rassure même si ça
rapporte rien mais on se dit bon ben
c'est quelque chose de métallique alors
que les euros un billet de 500 € c'est
juste un bout de papier
ça peu rassurer en en période de crise
où on se dit ça tiendra plus le coût que
d'autres
Non, moi j'ai j'ai simplement un doute
même sur le trading. C'est-à-dire que
en première
Oui, je je me dis
c'est toujours depuis quand ?
Ah bah depuis le 19e siècle.
Non non. Oui mais les produits
optionnels ça n'existe pas depuis le 19e
siècle qu'à un moment donné. Si c'est la
matière première, je désolé à Chicago,
c'est sur le marché de Chicago des
Futures qu'on démarré les premiers
dérivés sur les matières premières
agricoles.
Au 19e des dérivés. Ah oui oui oui plus
c'est plus que moi. Moi j'ai
l'impression en gros non les futurs des
marchés sur le futur. Oui
oui mais c'est
mais des options, il y en a Ah oui
ah non les options c'est années 70.
Voilà c'est les années 70. C'està-dire
que par rapport à ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur les innovations financières,
il y a toujours eu en effet des gens qui
ont fait les intermédiaires sur les
marchés de matière. Absolument. des
ventes à termes. À la fin, ça ressemble
à des ventes à terme. C'est-à-dire,
c'est des trucs assez basiques.
Là où j'ai un doute, c'est quand on a
euh sophistiquer les choses avec euh des
options. puisque j'observe que le la
première matière première travaillée,
c'est le pétrole,
h
que il y a un volume de produits dérivés
pharamineux sur le pétrole et on
n'arrive pas à démontrer que le pétrole
est plus stable depuis les années 70 où
on a commencé à injecter ces outils que
avant.
Oui, mais alors je suis pas sûr que ce
soit pour pour la raison que tuquelle tu
penses, c'est je dire le prix du
pétrole. Je crois pas que les options
sur le pétrole
ét source de volatilité sur ce marché
là. Je crois plus c'est que le pétrole
est un marché géopolitique et qui bouge
très enfin qui est hyper volatile dès
qu'il y a ici ou là
mais il est hyper volatile parce qu'on a
mis des leviers pour le rendre volatile
d'une certaine manière. C'est pas Trump
tout seul dans son bureau qui va appuyer
sur un bouton pour parce que c'est du
géopolitique. C'est qu'à un moment donné
plus on crée il paraît qu'il y a 50 € de
dérivé sur le pétrole pour 1 € un baril
pétrolier unique.
Et et donc à un moment donné tous ces
gens-là, ça veut dire qu'il y a toute
une faune qui se met à voir des avis sur
le pétrole et et des gens qui sinon
auraient fait autre chose, ils auraient
poussé des brouettes ailleurs. Et ben je
je dis que d'une certaine manière, on
injecte dans le système des gens dont le
métier et de dire ça va bouger comme si
ça va bouger comme ça et aux surprise ça
bouge.
Non mais alors ça c'est c'est tu as les
traders qui assurent la liquidité de ce
marchél optionnel c'est pas c'est pas le
diable. Ce qui crée un problème c'est
quand tu as des investisseurs
institutionnels qui commencent
effectivement à jepiler dans une classe
d'actif. Je pil, il faut expliquer
je pil à spéculer, à jouer euh sur la
hausse ou la baisse euh de du pétrole
comme classe d'actif.
Pas de jargon ici, hein.
Pas de jargon. Ouais.
Question de vos races. Euh, quelle
porosité entre les politiques et les
membres des conseils d'administration
des Big for ?
Des Big F,
c'était les comptables ? quatre plus
grosses banques.
Ah banqu les pas les
Ah oui, parce que sinon les comptables
c'est on les appelle les fatellement
ils sont gros. Ben, on va aussi faire
les comptables aussi he
entre les politiques et les conseils
d'administration des big for française.
Alors, j'essaie de me mémoriser les
conseillers d'administration des banques
françaises par rapport aux politiques.
Il y a rien qui me choque, mais j'ai
peut-être là cette année, je me suis
tapé 500 assemblées générales euh
analyse des résolutions dans le cadre de
ma fonction actuelle euh de donc de
d'entreprise côté un peu partout en
Europe. J'ai plus obligatoirement en
tête les conseils d'administration des
500 sociétés. Mais sur la porosité, si
on parle de conseil d'administration
entre les politiques euh et les conseils
d'administration des banques, j'ai rien
en tête. Toi peut-être tu as quelque
chose crois pas qu'il y a eu de
politique visible dans des conseils
d'administration de
Non, on on a un problème de revolving
doors. Euh c'est euh des politiques
euh donc les portes tournantes euh entre
privé et secteur public euh de euh
politique ou régulateur disons qui passe
dans le privé ou inversement. Donc en
France, on a eu la polémique sur la
Banque de France lorsque le gouverneur
de la Banque de France
Villoi de Galot était le l'ancien numéro
3 de la BNP et il est passé de l'un à
l'autre assez assez rapidement mais
c'est pas les conseils d'administration.
Alors autre question. Est-il vrai que
lorsqu'on fait marcher trop la planche à
billet cela mène à la guerre ?
Ça l'amène à la guerre.
Général, on dit ça pour l'Allemagne
qui a en effet eu une crise monétaire
dramatique dans les années 20 et puis
qui a attaqué tout le monde dans les
années 30. Mais c'est pas c'est pas
mécanique parce que beaucoup de gens
disent que c'est c'est pas vraiment ça
qui a créé la la la catastrophe
hitlérienne derrière. Non, c'est plus la
grande crise économique que euh la
planche habillée sur la République de
Vaimar.
Est-ce que vous avez lu euh euh
Confession d'un assassin économique ?
Non.
Non. Est-ce que c'est un bon livre ?
Autre question. Euh hop, je choisis.
On prend une op.
Alors, l'innovation financière, ça veut
dire dette. Point interrogation.
Pas obligatoirement, non ? pas
obligatoirement.
Enfin, à la base en gros le la banque
c'est quand même le crédit. Donc il y a
toujours dans un petit coin il y a un
élément dans l'innovation, il y a un
effet de levier mais qui est pas
obligatoirement de la dette. Alors comme
le mentionnait effectivement Jérôme dans
les options,
une option ça vous donne la possibilité,
le droit de éventuellement acheter
quelque chose à une date future en
mettant juste un peu d'argent sur la
table.
Et donc effectivement, ça c'est un des
produits dérivés. Il y a un effet de
levier
parce qu'on met peu d'argent mais si le
sous-jacent
augmente en valeur à l'avenir, avec le
peu d'argent que j'ai mis au début, je
peux grâce à l'effet de levier gagner
beaucoup d'argent. Mais il y a un paris,
il y a une spéculation.
Alors autre question. Comment vous
est-il possible de croire les chiffres
officiels de l'inflation ?
Ils sont ils sont officiels de moi je
suis un ancien statisticien donc je
défends je défends l'INC qui fait ça
extrêmement honnêtement. Le problème
c'est que notre économie est devenue
compliquée pour estimer l'inflation.
Certains peuvent dire l'inflation ne
veut plus dire grand-chose dans un monde
où on n'arrête pas d'innover sur des
produits qui sont de plus en plus des
produits de service. Comment arriver à
juger entre un smartphone et le
smartphone suivisant suivant quel est
l'élément amélioration du produit et
quel élément inflation ? En fait, on en
a aucune idée. On ne sait pas faire.
Donc, on est obligé de faire des
hypothèses dans tous les sens et parce
qu'on termine avec un chiffre, on pense
que c'est carré. Mais il y a eu des
hypothèses en effet au passage et on
peut se demander si l'inflation reste un
bon instrument d'analyse économique.
Mais je crois pas qu'il y ait de trucage
à l'INC euh en France.
Qui c'est qui disait euh je crois que
les statistiques que j'ai moi-même
bidouillé
sûrement pas un directeur de l'INC.
Non, je ne sais plus qui dis si c'est
George Vedel qui disait
c'était Churchill. Non, c'était quand il
y a une grosse comme ça là c'est
Sturchill en général.
Il y a George Vedel qui disait "Dans la
vie, il y a trois types de mensonges. Il
y a le petit mensonge, les gros
mensonges et les statistiques." Désolé.
Peut-on accuser Christine Lagarde de
laxisme
dans l'affaire tapis ?
Ouais, il y a peut-être beaucoup
d'autres d'affaires. Non,
de laxisme. Moi, j'ai pas de j'ai pas de
problème avec Christine Lagarde. Je suis
plutôt content qu'elle prenne la
direction de la BCE. Euh comme ça fait
une personne, une femme de plus, on va
dire aux commande euh et elle a
peut-être des casseroles
et elle est pas banquière. Et je crois
que de façon générale, plus de femmes au
poste de commande n'est pas une mauvaise
chose parce que alors on va dire que je
suis sexiste, pas du tout au contraire,
mais les femmes sont peut-être plus
raisonnables que les hommes. Il y a
moins de problèmes de testostérone et de
prise de risque inconsidéré. S'il y
avait eu plus de femmes patronnes de
banque, on aurait peut-être eu moins de
dégâts.
Ouais. Non, mais le on peut dire aussi
que les les femmes qui arrivent à à des
postes de pouvoir ont développé d'autres
pathologies, hein. C'est c'est pas des
questions de testostérone. Tiens, en
parlant de ça,
c'est un point de vue.
E euh
est-ce qu'il y a dans les salles de
marché, dans les institutions bancaires,
dans les dans l'élite financière qui a
le doigt peut-être sur le bouton
nucléaire ? Est-ce qu'il y a des
contrôles des contrôles antidrogues ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des évaluations
psychologiques chez les traders ? Euh,
est-ce qu'il y a des évaluations
psychologiques euh dans nos nos chers
banquiers ?
Où est-ce que ce serait peut-être bien
d'en avoir ?
Je ne sais pas trop. Il y avait des
rumeurs, là je terraai le nom, d'un très
grand patron de banque qui avait un
problème de cocaïne.
Il était peut-être pas tout seul, non ?
Oui, mais là, on parle de vraiment du
top niveau. Je parle pas d'un trader.
Est-ce que ça peut arriver ? Est-ce que
Est-ce que certaines personnes sous
pression peuvent se niffer ? Oui, ça
arrive. Est-ce que dans les salles de
marché mais il y a de moins en moins de
gens dans les salles de marché he c'est
de plus en plus les ordinateurs, hein,
qui font le boulot. Donc
les flash crack avec.
Voilà. Et et là on pas besoin d'avoir
sniffé. Mais dans les salles de marché,
il y a eu euh oui une époque où
effectivement ça se niffait euh pas mal
ou des problèmes d'alcoolisme, hein. Euh
c'est euh c'est un peu la la même
nature. Euh alors est-ce qu'il faut euh
je sais pas ce qu'il faut faire, mais
c'est ça ceement là c'est un problème
qu'on peut doit trouver dans toute
entreprise. Il faut peut-être
effectivement faire des tests euh en
matière de drogue ou autre
simplement burnout. De toute façon, ah
c'est vrai qu'on a on a eu, mais tu as
raison de dire que c'est en train de se
terminer par remplacement par des
machines, une culture de l'excès qui
faisait que suivant les gens prenait la
forme de de l'alcool, du burnout, mais
de toute façon euh de d'une forme de
déséquilibre.
On parle de Black Rock
parce que Black Rock est pas devenu trop
gros avec 6000 milliards d'actifs.
Alors moi je veux bien en parler. Enfin,
sauf si vas-y, vas-y, vas-y, tu il
connais mieux que moi.
Il y a eu un documentaire récemment
suré
suré euh qui est bourré d'amalgame.
Alors, qui est assez sens enfin
sensationnaliste
mais qui confond tout et n'importe quoi.
Alors là, je m'exprime en tant qu'ancien
un banquier. et confond les 6000
milliards de dollars d'actifs gérés par
Black Rock pour compte 2 tiers
et un bilan bancaire.
Alors, prenons une banque où il y a un
bilan bancaire de 2000 milliards
d'euros. Le BNP
par exemple, à peu près c'est cette
taille là, bravo.
Vous allez avoir
4 % de fond propre et 96 % de dettes.
Bon et ça respecte la réglementation. Là
je parle du de l'effet de levier réel.
Je parle pas des trucs bidouillés avec
les ratios de courtiine, avec des
risques auto-évalués et cetera. Bon,
mais donc il y a quand même 96 % de
dettes. Je reprends mon Black Rock et je
suis pas là pour défendre les Américains
mais j'aime bien une certaine rigueur
intellectuelle quand on parle de de ces
problèmes là. Les 6000 milliards de
dollars gérés, c'est pas au bilan de
Black Rock. Le bilan de Black Rock qui
est un bilan de société de gestion de
gérant d'actifs, il est pas très
important. C'est les capitaux gérés pour
comptes de tiers dans le cadre de SCAV,
de Mutual Funds et cetera qui
appartiennent à des ayants droits, des
caisses de retraite, monsieur Duchemol
et surtout dans ces 6000 milliards, sauf
sur quelques petits edge fronts, il y a
pas un PT d'endettement.
Donc c'est à droite du bilan de la
sicave, c'est que des fonds propres
puisque ce sont les parts des détenteurs
et à gauche des actifs. Donc c'est pas
la même nature. Et quand on présente le
géant Black Rock comme l'affreux,
l'abominable, peu transparent que
personne ne connaît et puis en plus dans
le terme Black Rock, il y a Black donc
c'est la force du mal, la force noire,
c'est un peu excessif. Cela étant dit,
tout n'est pas génial non plus chez
Black Rock, hein. Ils ont un patron qui
a tendance à être très tendance dans ses
déclarations sur certains sujet
comme quoi
sur tout ce qui est ESG, ce genre de
choses. Et puis ensuite les gérants
d'actif,
pardon euh tout ce qui alors ESG c'est
un alors c'est RSE en français, c'est
responsabilité sociétale de
l'entreprise. SG c'est en anglais et et
donc Larifing qui est le grand patron
fait beaucoup de déclarations qui vont
dans le sens disons du vent mais ensuite
ces gérants d'actifs en bas quand ils
prennent des décisions de gestion qui
est je vais acheter l'action chelle ou
je vais vendre total ou je vais bon là
bon c'est autre chose.
C'est le problème c'est la taille quand
même. C'est-à-dire que tu as tout à fait
raison. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas un
risque structurel. Non,
comme il peut y avoir dans une banque.
Le le problème qu'il y a, c'est de se
dire pourquoi est-ce qu'on est rassuré à
à concentrer euh les décisions chez des
normes animaux ? En quoi est-ce que
c'est un qu'est-ce qui fait que notre
économie favorise la croissance à
l'infini ? Ça c'est exponentiel dans
tous les domaines.
Dans tous les domaines. C'est-à-dire
qu'en fait on est dans un système qui
dit plus que c'est le système
capitaliste d'une certaine manière parce
que comme tu le dis, il y a un tout
petit capital parce que s'il y a pas
c'est pas un bilan de banque sur Black
Rock mais plus j'aurai une grande
activité plus que mon petit capital
crachera. Donc on a on a un système
d'économie d'échelle qui fait qu'on a
intérêt à croître à l'infini et qu'il y
a plus de force de contrôlevier.
C'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui Black Rock
est multiplié par 10. Personne viendra
dire attention vous avez un vous avez un
problème. Les lois anti concurrence ont
l'air d'être passé à la trappe aux
États-Unis. Euh donc on est dans un
monde où on a la possibilité de croître
à l'infini et tôt ou tard
pardon
dans un monde fini.
Oui dans un monde fini. C'est on sent
bien à un moment donné on a vu, moi je
parle toujours dans en comparaison avec
le politique à un moment donné la
colonisation finie. Les États ont appris
qu'ils devaient vivre les uns avec les
autres et que s'ils avaient cette
taille-là, bah ils en auraient pas une
plus grande. Et donc à un moment donné
euh dans un monde fini, on est obligé
d'accepter l'idée que euh si on veut
vivre en en communauté, on doit pas
avoir des animaux qui ont des tailles
complètement déséquilibrés.
Quand on fait juste une petite
parenthèse sur Black Rock, quand il y a
il y a Carl qui pique, on voit bien dans
la vidéo de de qui pique au vif le
directeur général de de Black Rock en
disant voilà je résume trivialement, il
y a il y a il fait une blague, il dit
voilà
tout le monde est dans un bus, c'est
Larry qui conduit et c'est Jeanette qui
pousse. Il se dirige vers la la falaise.
Jeanette Héen à l'époque qui était à la
tête de la la Fed
et qui et et on se dirige vers un gros
rocher et ça et et ça va nous créer une
crise financière. C'était quoi ? C'est
une blagounette. Il il voulait manipuler
le le cours de l'action de Black Rock.
Non, il voulait pas manipuler le cours
de l'action de Black Rock. Bon, faut
aussi connaître Carlyan, hein. D'où
vient-il ? un raideur hein. Bon moi
quand j'étais banquier aux États-Unis
donc il y a longtemps
un raideur
un raideur donc c'était en l'occurrence
un monsieur qui a gagné beaucoup
d'argent comme ça qui lançait des offres
publiques d'achat hostile sur des
entreprises côté en bourse mais qui
avait surtout disons l'optique à
l'époque c'était de menacer d'une offre
publique hostile pour se faire racheter
les 5 % qu'il avait pris au capital avec
une prime par rapport au cours pour de
bourse, ce qu'on appelle aussi des
raiders, mais on appelle ça du green
mail. Bon, donc il a un peu sulfureux
hein Carlan,
il était dans la provocation, c'est plus
moi je l'ai plus senti comme deux disons
financiers de très haut niveau
américain,
l'un ayant besoin de bousculer l'autre
pour se faire un peu un peu remarquer.
Les cryptoonnaies, on y croit, on n'y
croit pas. Euh c'est intéressant la
blockchain dans la finance.
Je crois pas trop moi au aux
cryptomonnaie, c'estàd je pense que là
encore c'est un un oxyor parce que la la
la monnaie c'est la confiance et que
cryptomonnaie non n'attire pas la
confiance au contraire. Donc
le piano est trop loin du tabouret pour
que à un moment donné une cryptoonnaie
basique arrive arrive à vraiment
séduire. Après, ça dépend des
cryptonnaies. C'est-à-dire que si les
parrains les faits autour du berceau
sont suffisamment importants, si on
prend par exemple les tentatives
Facebook Libra, ça peut un peu changer.
Pour le reste, j'ai un peu du mal à
imaginer un succès.
Euh oui. Alors, je je ne sais pas ce que
je rappellerai quand même parce que tu
parlais de confiance, c'est que Bitcoin
ça a été créé au plus fort de la crise
de 2008 justement parce que la confiance
avait été rompue et que le mécanisme du
blockchain, alors on oublie Bitcoin en
tant que tel qui est spéculatif
et et on raisonne blockchain.
blockchain, c'est un registre
décentralisé qui permet justement de
rétablir la confiance. comme la nature à
horreur du vide, euh il y a peut-être
des voies pour l'avenir. On a quand même
vu, alors comme d'habitude lorsqu'il y a
des innovations,
disons qu'il y aura du tri qui se fera
au fil du temps. Mais si je dis pas de
bêtises, de nos jours, il y a quelque
chose comme 500 ou 600
cryptomonnaies qui sont peut-être plutôt
des cryptoactifs que des monnaies parce
qu'elles n'ont pas les caractéristiques
requises d'une monnaie qui est moyen de
paiement
conservé de la valeur. Et puis j'ai
oublié le le troisème critère et il est
clair que pour l'instant le Bitcoin qui
fait ça n'est pas une réserve de valeur.
Mais on sent quand même sur le Bitcoin,
ce qui est hyper spéculatif que je
regarde moi tous les jours, je
n'achèterai jamais un Bitcoin à titre
perso, c'est que quand il y a un peu des
coups de chaud, là on sent que le cours
du Bitcoin se remonte comme l'or. Bon,
il y a un peu cette volatilité. Il y a
quelques personnes, je recommande pas
d'investir en Bitcoin, hein. Euh qu' y a
quelques person et dans l'or ? Et dans
l'or euh moi j'ai toujours trouvé ça
stérile mais euh
ça a un potentiel de disons pour un peu
plus garder une certaine valeur en cas
de crise sévère et de fuite devant la
monnaie. C'est euh le le C'est vrai, je
m'exprimais moi sur les les monnaies et
le blockchain c'est quelque chose
d'autre. C'est en effet une technologie.
Euh il faut quand même voir que
premièrement,
la raison pour laquelle ce genre de
technologie apparaît, c'est euh le fait
qu'il y a de plus en plus de capacités
informatiques dont on sait pas quoi
faire et qu'à un moment donné, ce
trucl-là bouffe une capacité
informatique absolument vertigineuse. Et
il y a un autre élément
pour le minage.
Pour le minage, oui, pas pour les autres
cryptos.
Bon, OK.
Et l'autre élément, c'est de dire euh
par rapport à est-ce que c'est l'avenir
au fond de la façon de vivre ensemble
entre êtres humains ? c'est de se dire
on va dépenser une énergie énorme pour
éviter d'avoir à se faire confiance
entre nous. Et c'est ça qui me semble
moi relativement effrayant par rapport à
la à la manière dont on fonctionne
puisque le seul avantage c'est de dire
on n'est plus obligé de se faire
confiance les uns et les autres. On va
répliquer des milliers de fois
l'information et donc comme ça a été
répliqué des milliers de fois, ce sera
très dur à frauder.
Et quand même, ça occupe beaucoup
beaucoup de de place d'ordinateur parce
que d'une certaine manière, si tu dois
répliquer 1000 fois une information et
que tout le monde se met à répliquer
1000 fois une information, à la fin,
c'est vrai qu'il nous faut 1000 fois
plus d'ordinateurs.
D'accord. Mais alors c'est je crois
c'est quelqu'un que vous avez dû inviter
qui est monsieur Jean Covici
Jean-Marc. Voilà qui disait parce que
quand on là moi je parle plus de de la
blockchain qui est une techno qu'il faut
préserver à tout prix, qu'il faut pas
balancer avec euh le disons le bébé et
l'eau du bain euh avec le Bitcoin.
La blockchain est fortement
consommatrice d'énergie mais je crois
que donc Jean-Marc Jeancovici
et de mémoire d'ordinateur disait
surtout c'est que en fait en matière
d'empreinte carbone aujourd'hui sur tout
ce qui est internet et autres c'est pas
le Bitcoin
c'est ce que nous sommes en train de
faire c'est les vidéos les vidéos ça ça
consomme un maximum et beaucoup plus
c'est la première consommation d'après
ce que j'ai cru comprendre
c'est pour ça qu'on fait du du podcast
aussi et qu'on fait on a la possibilité
d'avoir nos vidéos en basse résolution
pour éviter de trois petits problèmes
comme ça. Jérôme, tu voulais rajouter un
mot ?
Non non non.
OK. On va parler euh euh la
privatisation ADP, la Française des
jeux,
euh les barrages hydrauliques
EDF, c'est bien, c'est pas bien. C'est
parce qu'il y a plus de sous dans les
soutes qu'on est obligé de brader les
bijoux de famille. C'est quoi ?
ce qui ce qui d'une certaine manière on
peut avoir une position idéologique pour
ou contre les nationalisations.
Prétatisation.
Oui. Ou les privatisations. C'est
symétrique. À un moment donné, on arrive
dans une France de 2019 où il y a par
exemple une Française des jeux qui est
publique.
On peut dire il y a une connerie de fête
par si on est contre par exemple les
nationalisations. On peut dire c'est
génial. Mais à la fin des phases, ce qui
m'intéresse moi, c'est le jeu qui se
passe quand on passe de quelque chose
qui était public à quelque chose qui
était privé. Pour moi, on est forcément
dans un truc qui est malsin parce que
une des raisons pour lesquelles on a une
française des jeux, c'est qu'on
considère que les jeux avec les
phénomènes d'accoutumance comme le
crédit sont des machins qui doivent être
un peu surveillés de près.
Et la Française des jeux n'a pas été
toujours blanc bleu dans ce domaine là
d'une certaine manière. C'est comme le
crédit, c'est quand même une manière de
piquer de l'argent aux pauvres pour
aller le mettre ailleurs. Euh donc la
Française des jeux de mains privée, pour
attirer des investisseurs, on est quand
même obligé de leur laisser entendre que
ils vont pouvoir développer leur
business parce que sinon on trouve pas
d'investisseur ou alors on trouve ou
alors c'est une mauvaise affaire pour
l'État. Et donc on est contraint à un
moment donné de donner du mou sur
quelque chose sur lequel on n pas
forcément envie de donner du mou. Et on
va avoir derrière des gens qui seront
venus avec une optique de se dire "Je
viens avec une optique financière et je
vais me refaire de mon investissement."
Ce qui est complètement normal de la
part d'un investisseur. Et donc il me
semble qu'on a une contradiction entre
l'intérêt collectif et l'intérêt et
l'intérêt individuel. sur l'aéroport
Christophe.
Sur l'aéroport euh j'ai pas d'opinion
tranchée. Il s'agit d'une
infrastructure. Euh on a une mauvaise
qui rapporte
pardon
l'infrastructure
aéroport de Paris.
Oui oui oui. Euh
il y a beaucoup de fonciers aussi. Non
il y a du foncier aussi. Je connais pas
le dossier sur sur le sur le bout des
doigts. Non, je mentionnerai seulement
c'est que en matière de privatisation
d'infrastructure, on avait eu une
mauvaise expérience dans le passé avec
les autoroutes. Euh donc faut être un
peu prudent quand on parle
d'infrastructure parce que
infrastructure c'est un bien public.
Bon, alors un aéroport c'est un peu
différent d'une autoroute, mais c'est
quand même assez stratégique sur un
pays. Donc voilà, je serais disons,
est-ce que vous y voyez à peu près la
même chose que pendant le l'effondrement
de l'Xction Union soviétique
quand les bijoux de famille de l'ACU
soviétique sont partis ?
C'est différent parce queà l'époque
c'était un grand pillage
quand il y a eu l'effondrement de
l'Empire soviétique où on a filé donc
fameux oligarques des entreprises
publiques
pour une poignée de figue entreprise
publique derrière laquelle ils ont fait
quand même pas mal de boulot parce que
c'était un peu poussiéreux et cetera
mais donc pour une poignée de figue il y
a de très grosses fortunes qui ont été
qui ont été créées. Là, je crois pas que
dans le cas français, on est dans ce
même processus. Il y a pas dans les
privatisations françaises, si je dis pas
de bêtises, un Pékin qui a qui est
devenu milliardaire grâce à la
privatisation de des autoroutes. Non,
mais en fait, il y a quand même des
entreprises qui ont gagné beaucoup
d'argent et et l'un des éléments qui a
été choquant dans cette histoire de
d'aéroport de Paris, c'est qu'un certain
nombre de gens ont eu l'impression que
c'était promis à Vincy. Euh qui avait
déjà quand même euh bien beuré sa
tartine sur le euh sur les autoroutes et
qu'on s'est dit ça va encore se passer
dans un sac entre trois copains. Et
c'est vrai que le voilà le contribuable
de base se dit ça à bon de me dire queon
va me je
Oui. Enfin, moi en tant que contribuable
de base, c'est vrai que j'apprécie pas
ça. Non, j'apprécie pas.
Autre question internet. L'euro va-t-il
résister
à la prochaine crise ?
Le problème de l'euro, c'est que c'est
une monnaie qui est incomplète et
une monnaie habituellement
c'est adossé
à un état avec un pouvoir budgétaire qui
est la capacité de lever des impôts et
ce qui donne cette crédibilité à la
monnaie. Bon, l'euro a été mal ficelé
pour des raisons politiques
qui il fallait le faire et on a négocié
la création de la monnaie unique que nos
amis allemands ont accepté avec
difficulté mais c'était la monnaie
d'échange pour du côté français dans ce
couple infernal franco-allemand accepter
la réunification allemande.
Donc on a créé l'euro mais les Allemands
n'en voulaient pas. Et comme ils n'en
voulaient pas, ils les ont accepté au
travers des traités de rigueur
budgétaire et surtout qu'il n'y ait pas
de budget européen. Parce que la grande
crainte des Allemands, après on pourrait
parler d'autres choses d'ailleurs, c'est
de devoir se retrouver à financer les
autres pays européens puisqu'ils
considèrent qu'ils sont vertueux et que
le reste de l'Europe, hein, qu'on
appelait les pays du club M là au sud,
on a parlé de Grèce et cetera, les pigs,
les cochons, mais aussi clubm, c'est
moins c'est moins péjoratif comme la
Grèce. Ils ont toujours considéré que
ces pays-là n'étaient pas vertueux et
qu'il y avait juste le germain qui était
vertueux. Ce dont on pourrait parler,
c'est que fin donc l'euro, est-ce qu'il
va résister ? Je ne sais pas. C'est une
monnaie incomplète, donc c'est une très
grosse faiblesse.
Ce que je voudrais quand même rajouter
par rapport à l'euro et nos amis
Germains, ce qu'ils oublient, c'est que
l'euro est grossièrement 20 à 30 %
en dessous de ce qui était le
Deutchmark.
qui du coup leur a donné un avantage
compétitif à l'export.
Or, les pays du sud eux avaient
l'inverse, c'est-à-dire un euro qui
était surévalué par rapport à leur
monnaie nationale, que ce soit la Dragme
ou bon ou même le franc français. Donc
ils ont été quand même les grands
bénéficiaires. Donc quand nos amis
allemands viennent nous donner de très
grandes leçons de gestion, de rigueur et
cetera, euh peut-être quand même aussi
leur rappeler que c'est grâce à 7 € euh
qu'ils sont aussi vertueux. Mais c'est
pas compliqué dans ces cas-là.
Jérôme, le Brexit, c'est quoi le Brexit
? et les les redneck qui se réveillent
comme aux États-Unis et qui ont décidé
de dire merde leur politique. C'est du
protectionnisme, c'est un repli
identitaire. C'est quoi ?
J'ai pas d'idée très originale sur le
Brexit. Je pense que pour on est
spectateur quand même en France, il peut
nous arriver des choses désagréables,
mais d'une certaine manière, c'est nos
amis anglais qui sont au en première
ligne là-dessus. Ça montre à quel point
euh la politique a une importance et et
avoir les mauvais hommes politiques au
mauvais moment euh peut coûter
relativement cher euh à une économie. Je
pars je je suis pas de ceux qui disent
que à la fin l'Angleterre va gagner, que
ça va la renforcer extraordinairement.
J'ai un ami qui croit ça. Bon peut-être.
Moi j'y crois pas du tout. J'observe
queils sont dans un dans un déchirement
intérieur abominable depuis plusieurs
années et qu'on a pas l'impression qu'il
soit plus près aujourd'hui d'en sortir
que euh queil y a 3 ans. Euh et donc
voilà, ils se sont mis dans un corner
eux-mêmes avec
un référendum qui a mal tourné. Euh
après euh est-ce qu'il faut dramatiser
cette question ? Je sais que à l'époque,
on l'a dramatisé en Europe. On a dit
"Oui, il y en a un qui part aujourd'hui,
mais demain il y en aura deux, il y en
aura trois." Ce sera globalement
l'Europe s'est plutôt bien comporté, a
fait la tortue
et et le problème il est chez les
Britanniques qui sont en train de de
plus être sûr.
It les italiens quand même, ça leur
donne des petites idées, non ?
Bah là, ils sont ils sont un peu calmés
les nos amis italiens depuis
depuis quelques mois. Donc aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs, on voit un certain reflux de
cette vague qui était censée nous noyer
complètement de de
de la droite populiste.
Donc moi, j'ai l'impression d'une
certaine manière que on est en train de
s'habituer tous à l'idée que c'est plus
facile de ce côté de la Manche que de
l'autre côté, qui vont finir par s'y
habituer aussi du côté du côté des
Anglais mais qu'à la fin ils auront pas
gagné.
Christophe Brexit
sur le Brexit
aura des répercussions financières.
Çaen a déjà eu par rapport à la parité
de la livre.
Je crois pas que ça va avoir d'autres
impacts fort sur le secteur financier à
Londres. Quand le Brexit a été annoncé,
des gens ont dit il va y avoir des
pertes d'emploi monstrueux dans le
secteur financier. He je parle pas de
l'automobile euh à Londres. Moi, j'avais
fait une estimation au doigt mouillé et
on n'y est pas. J'avais dit maximum
50000 emplois qui vont être délocalisés
de la City. C'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui. Pourquoi Londres restera
toujours Londres en tant que centre
financier ? parce que c'est un microcom,
c'est une culture,
tout ça fonctionne très très bien et que
du coup ça restera la première place
financière européenne. Alors qu' des
parts de marché à prendre sur la
compensation, peu importe les trucs
techniques, oui, mais croire à
l'écroulement de la finance londonienne,
moi je je n'y crois pas du tout.
Macron, c'est un bon président ou pas ?
C'est une question très vache ça.
Ah bah on dit on dit
parce que non mais c'est c'est très
vache parce que à la limite ça nous
demande ou ça me demande et ce que je ne
souhaite pas faire c'est afficher une
opinion politique.
Est-ce qu'il a des résultats ?
Non mais là tu tournes autour du P.
Jérôme,
je suis pas je suis pas un fan euh je
suis pas un fan de Macron. Euh je l'ai
jamais aimé. C'est-à-dire, je pense que
on a on a aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de grands problèmes collectifs euh dans
les démocraties que ces problèmes
collectifs, c'est notamment d'arriver à
réconcilier euh différents bouts qui
aujourd'hui euh ont l'impression que la
règle du jeu ne fonctionne plus pour
eux. C'estàd qu'ils peuvent pas vraiment
gagner, qu'il y en a d'autres qui vont
systématiquement gagner, que tout ça est
pas fairplay et que le discours sur les
gagnants n'est pas un bon discours. Je
je pense qu'il faut se représenter une
société comme un jeu. En effet, j'aime
bien le jeu, mais dans un jeu, les
gagnants ont besoin des perdants et il
faut que ça se rejoue, il faut qu'on
rebatte les cartes et qu'à un moment
donné croire que euh c'est les gagnants
peuvent s'en tirer tout seul. C'est
d'une immense naïveté
euh et et je pense que c'est un péché de
jeunesse, c'est-à-dire il a la tête il a
la tête bien faite. C'est ce que
j'espère. J'ai pas voté pour lui, je
voterai pas pour lui une autre fois,
mais à un moment donné il est notre
président. Donc s'il va au mur en
klaxonnant, c'est pas non plus voilà,
c'est c'est pas ça me fera pas ça me
fera pas sauter de joie.
Moi, je me dis en toute modestie que
quand j'avais son âge, je devais un peu
penser comme lui. Et et je crois qu'on
on apprend en en mûrissant qu'en fait
dans ce dans un jeu, tout le monde doit
y gagner quelque chose et on doit
pouvoir rejouer et et on doit pouvoir
avoir des perdants qui sont pas amè et
des gagnants qui ont pas la morgue qui
croient pas que c'est grâce à eux. Oui,
c'est un peu grâce à eux, mais c'est pas
uniquement grâce à eux. S'ils ont pas eu
tout le collectif autour d'eux, et ben
ils auraient rien gagné du tout. Et et
et donc j'espère qu'il va murir et qu'à
un moment donné, il va arriver avec un
discours un peu plus englobant. Je suis
tout à fait d'accord sur l'aspect
collaboratif du jeu.
Je suis un libéral mais quand je vois
certains
entrepreneurs ou patrons qui donne
l'impression que
il crée tout seul des emplois que c'est
grâce à eux et cetera, peut-être quand
même leur rappeler. Alors ce sont des
leaders très bien bon mais que bah il y
a aussi des salariés et que si les
salariés le matin ne se levaient pas
pour venir travailler, son entreprise
n'existerait pas. Donc euh il y a ce
côté collaboratif euh qui en fait sont
des des des
mécanismes sociétaux de vivre ensemble
qu'il faut pas négliger. Euh j'aime
beaucoup les entrepreneurs, mais croire
que c'est grâce à eux que le pays tourne
et que tous les autres sont des
fonctionnaires qui ne font rien ou sont
des assistés, c'est à mon avis c'est pas
la bonne lecture de comment une société
doit fonctionner. Le ruissellement,
c'est une grosse escroquerie
intellectuelle. Ah,
on développe
mais moi je dis tout simplement
là-dessus, enfin le trickling effecton
manger tous les matins au petit-déjeuner
?
Je veux dire quoi par là ? C'est quand
vous avez une certaine accumulation de
richesse, c'est pas de l'effet de
ruissellement.
C'est ça va être de l'épargne
supplémentaire qui sera en partie
investie. je suis d'accord avec toi sur
les marchés financiers qui permet à ce
moment-là d'augmenter encore plus disons
le patrimoine ou le capital. Donc on
nous avait vendu ça comme ce sont les
entrepreneurs,
les bons parce que la piétaille ce sont
que des fénias qui vont ruisseler sur le
reste de l'économie grâce à au fait
queon va porter des montres Rolex et
avoir des sacs Louis Vitton ou je ne
sais quoi. Bon non, ça suffit. Moi, j'ai
toujours une comparaison simple, c'est
de dire
on a tous, je pense joué, même encore
mes petits enfants, ils jouent au
monopolie.
Le monopoly qui est censé représenter
l'économie capitaliste et qui la
représente pas mal. C'est un peu
simplifié mais c'est pas mal. C'est
hyper brutal. Il y a pas il y a pas le
facteur triche quand même dedans hein.
Non, il y a pas le facteur triche. Mais
la triche, on on a beau dire le problème
du système c'est pas la triche. Voilà, à
un moment donné, c'est peut-être qu'on
est trop molaçon et que si on tolère
trop de triche. Mais donc dans dans le
monopoi, y compris des gens qui sont pas
libéraux, aiment bien jouer au monopoly.
Mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on aime bien
jouer au monopolie ? C'est parce que à
la fin du jeu, on sait que si on refait
un jeu, celui qui avait des hôtels, il
les aura pas à la partie suivante.
Et et d'une certaine manière, c'est ça
qui rend le gagnant sympathique et qui
rend le perdant pas trop amè. et et donc
d'une certaine manière, tant qu'on aura
pas compris ça sur le plan sur le plan
économique également et ben on arrivera
pas euh on narrivera pas à bien vivre
ensemble. Et la théorie du ruissellement
c'est je l'ai vécu aussi quand j'étais
petit que je jouais au monopolie. C'est
quand en gros vous dites voilà je suis
en train de gagner, c'est génial les
pauvres couillons ils passent chez moi,
ils me payent des tomb d'argent chaque
fois qu'il tombent dans mes hôtels et
ils sont ruinés. Ah c'est embêtant. Mais
je vais leur donner un peu d'argent pour
leur mettre le nez hors de l'eau parce
que je prends tellement de plaisir à
cette partie que je vais continuer.
Et voilà, c'est en gros je vais
ruisseler un peu d'argent et le jeu va
continuer. Mais sauf que j'ai besoin
d'eux pour jouer parce que si à un
moment donné il m'envoie le le le
plateau de jeu à la tête, qu'est-ce que
je vais faire avec mes petits hôtels
rouges moi ? Donc le le problème du
ruissolement c'est que c'est pas vrai.
Ça ça marche pas. Et le fait que ce soit
pas vrai, il y a des tas de trucs pas
vrais auxquels on croit, mais c'est qu'à
un moment donné, on risque de casser
l'envie de jouer d'un certain nombre de
gens dont il était quand même nécessaire
au système. Et ce jour-là, c'est très
dur à remonter.
Christophe,
alors je voulais juste rajouter, c'est
que dans le Monopoly, il y a quand même
toujours on pioche des cartes et de
temps à autre, on peut se retrouver en
prison. Ne passer pas par la case
départ, ne collectez pas 20000 €.
Tu as raison. Mais si tu es si tu es mal
parti, elle te sauvera jamais la carte
au monopolie. Quand tu es mal parti,
c'est foutu. D'accord. C'était juste
pour dire c'est que au monopolie, il y
avait du pénal. Il y avait quand même du
pénal. C'est vrai. La prison.
Ouais. un peu candide parce que là on
est au 21e siècle, il y a toujours des
grandes dynasties.
C'est il y a des gens qui partent avec
une cuillère dorée dans la bouche très
facilement qui font les mêmes écoles et
mais l'égalité, personne n'en a vraiment
envie de l'égalité totale. Enfin, je je
connais pas grand monde parce que c'est
d'une certaine manière, on aime bien
tous gagner de temps en temps quelque
chose. Pour moi, le problème c'est pas
euh l'inégalité, c'est ou les inégalités
disproportionnées qui font qu'on va pas
jouer avec un mec de 200 kg si soi-même
on en fait 65 hein. Euh ou c'est ce
refus de rebattre les cartes, cette idée
que si on a perdu à un moment donné, on
a perdu toute sa vie et l'autre il va
gagner toute sa vie. Donc il y a un
certain nombre de règles du jeu qui sont
relativement simples à comprendre et on
peut relativement bien comprendre
pourquoi quand on les viole ça marche
pas.
Alors dernière question internet.
Possibilité de fermer les bourses en cas
de crash.
Euh oui,
toutes oui,
mais
enfin les fermer définitivement ou le
temps que les choses se calment ?
Ouais,
je pense que c'est temporairement.
Oui,
je pense.
Donc on arrive à la fin de notre
interview. Je vais vous demander à
chacun trois bouquins, trois livres et
ensuite un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Christophe,
trois livres. donc que je conseillerai
trois livres et un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Alors, trois livres. Alors, désolé si je
le dis en anglais. un livre écrit par un
historien
israélien
qui s'appelle monsieur Harari
qui est sapience
Brief History of Humanind
qui été traduit dans 37 pays et c'est
l'histoire de haut niveau qui remonte à
une histoire plus ancienne de nos
sociétés que depuis 20 siècles.
Tu as lieu au Modéus ?
Pardon ?
Au Modéus ? Alors, au modéus, c'est le
suivant. Je cale, j'en suis à la moitié.
Là, j'ai plus de difficultés. J'ai plus
de difficulté parce que le premier
livre, c'est celui d'un historien et le
second livre, il devient dans la
projection ou la prévision qui est une
autre à mon avis, c'est une autre
casquette, mais bon, c'est un opinion
personnelle. Donc, ça piens super. Un
autre bouquin qui m'a fait euh ouvrir
les yeux sur les États-Unis, que
j'adore. J'ai vécu 10 ans aux
États-Unis. C'était vraiment dans ma
prime jeunesse des années très
sympathiques dans les années 80. Le
bouquin, alors là aussi le titre anglais
c'est The Hand told euh history of the
United States, donc l'histoire non
raconté des États-Unis, écrit par un
historien dont j'ai oublié le nom et
quelqu'un que vous connaissez euh qui
est Oliver Stone, le producteur euh euh
de film et qui raconte une histoire des
États-Unis qu'on a jamais vu dans les
livres d'histoire et c'est vraiment
passionnant. Le 3e livre. Le 3è livre.
Qu'est-ce que je lis en ce moment ? Euh
qu'est-ce que je lis en ce moment ?
Ouais. Non, c'est un polar, ça pas ça a
pas grand intérêt.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Non,
un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Euh
alors, je sais que ça va pas faire
plaisir à beaucoup de gens. Sur les
jeunes générations, moi ce qui me frappe
le plus, c'est une éthique qui a
profondément changé par rapport au
travail
et les jeunes générations devraient
peut-être parfois faire un petit peu
plus d'effort, être moins dans
l'immédiateté de je veux quelque chose
et savoir que bah dans le travail, il y
a une certaine éthique et puis il faut
quand même bosser si on veut obtenir des
choses et pas juste exiger.
Jérôme, trois bouquins, un conseil. Euh
alors les trois bouquins, je croyais que
tu en demandais qu'un. Donc je m'étais
préparé pour un Donc moi ce que j'avais
noté c'était un un tout petit petit
livre d'une Véronique Dequer, l'école
publique émancipatrice
qui euh d'une ancienne directrice
d'école euh qui en 120 pages vous vous
délivre un nombre d'évidences sur
l'enseignement qui est qui vraiment vous
ouvre les yeux, vous éclaire. Pourtant,
je suis d'une famille où il y en a, mais
c'est vraiment
1 heure et demi très agréable. Et puis
alors, je rajoute ce que je suis en
train de lire en ce moment. Euh ça fait
un peu grosse tête mais euh c'est qu'on
rade au cœur des ténèbres que j'avais
jamais lu à mon âge avancé et j'ai
découvert d'abord que c'était très court
et que c'est absolument euh fascinant
sur la brutalité occidentale vis-à-vis
de l'Afrique et donc que je recommande
également chaudement.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Alors, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, intéressez-vous et la
politique. Laissez pas les autres s'en
occuper pour vous.
Messieur, merci.
Merci à toi. Bonsoir
[Musique]